Guys, let's just scooch in here real quick. Let's just wedge our way in here right before we're going to start anew. But I just want to scooch right in here, right before we start and just kind of look at you in the eye. Yeah, do like a little appetizer, a little audio appetizer. Yeah, a little appetizer. Just get a little scooch in, just kind of like a quick little wink and hello. Yeah, Sean, let's just make it a twosome today.
伙计们，我们赶紧在这儿挤挤。就在我们要重新开始之前，赶紧在这儿塞进去。但我只想在开始前挤到这儿，看着你们的眼睛。对，来点开胃菜，来点音频开胃菜。对，来点开胃菜。稍微挤一下，就像快速抛个媚眼打个招呼。对，肖恩，今天就咱们俩吧。
Okay, ready? Here we go. Welcome to Smartless. Yes! I'm Wedged In. Who's that other guy? I'm still Wedged In. Here we go. I'm Sean. I'm a smart lousy
好了，准备好了吗？我们开始。欢迎来到《聪明无能》。太棒了！我被挤进来了。那另外一个家伙是谁？我还在被挤着。我们开始吧。我是肖恩。我是个聪明又无能的
Sean where'd you get that sweet smartless hat? Isn't that cool? From the merch store at SiriusXM. So you go to SiriusXM you can just buy like smartless like t-shirts hats and like what if I wanted like leg warmers? Do they have those? Yes. Yes.
肖恩，你从哪弄的那个超酷的“聪明无能”帽子？是不是很酷？从SiriusXM的周边商店买的。所以你去SiriusXM就能买到像“聪明无能”的T恤帽子之类的，那如果我想要像腿套之类的呢？他们有吗？有。有。
Yes. You could do all that. You know. Do they have those? Why? Yes, yes. Yes, you could do all that. You know. Do we get any, does anyone? This was sent to me though. I think we talked about this before. Yeah, why'd they send us that? I got one of those too. I don't know, did you get it or no?
有。你全都能买到。你知道的。他们有那种东西吗？为什么？有，有。对，你全都可以买到。你知道的。我们能拿到吗，有人能拿到吗？不过这个是寄给我的。我想我们之前讨论过这个。对，为什么他们给我们寄那个？我也收到一个。我不知道，你收到了没有？
I did get it. Why did they send us one of those hats? They're particularly proud of it? I don't know, because they're like new, I guess, in the store. They're pretty sweet. Amanda stole mine immediately. Now, who came up with those?
我确实收到了。为什么他们要给我们寄这种帽子？他们特别为这感到自豪吗？我不知道，可能是因为它们是商店里新出的吧。它们挺酷的。阿曼达立刻把我的给偷走了。话说，这到底是谁设计的？
Sean, you had a hand in that particular hat, right? No, I didn't. I haven't, no, not at all. Will's got notes, hold on, hold on, hold on. Well, Will wants a trucker hat. This is like a baseball hat. Will likes a trucker hat. It's not a baseball hat.
肖恩，那顶帽子你也有份参与设计吧？不，我没有。我没有，完全没有。威尔有意见，等等，等等，等等。好吧，威尔想要一顶卡车司机帽。这是一顶棒球帽。威尔喜欢卡车司机帽。这不是棒球帽。
It's got a real curve on the bill. It is a trucker hat, which I like, but it's got a real soft top to it. It kind of rolls back. I like a high top to my trucker hat. We call that, it's almost got a slouch, and I don't like it. Yeah, I know you.
它的帽檐有很大的弧度。它确实是一顶卡车司机帽，我挺喜欢的，但它顶部非常柔软。它会往后塌。我喜欢帽冠比较高的卡车司机帽。我们管这叫，它几乎有点下垂感，我不喜欢。对，我了解你。
But you can find the high top trucker hats on the site there. Yes, you can. Where is that, Sean? It's at the Sirius XM, I don't know the link. Does anybody know the link? I don't know. Well, we'll put it in the chat.
不过你可以在那边的网站上找到高帽冠的卡车司机帽。是的，你可以。那是哪儿，肖恩？在Sirius XM上，我不知道网址。有人知道网址吗？我不知道。好吧，我们会把它发到聊天框里。
Yeah. Everyone's getting the chat, right? Oh yeah, we should get, oh yeah, people are jumping on the chat, right? Oh, hang on. Let me just take a look that chat is blowing up. Wait, Jay. Did you make it to Maples game? I did I saw the first quarter and she was I was telling will Yeah She's got incredible ball skills, which is what I think Sean's or Will's handle one
对。每个人都能看到聊天框，对吧？哦对，我们应该，哦对，大家都在涌入聊天框，对吧？哦，等等。我来看一眼，聊天框彻底炸了。等等，杰伊。你去看枫叶队的比赛了吗？去了，我看了第一节，她当时，我正在跟威尔说，对，她有不可思议的球技，我觉得这就是肖恩或者威尔的梗——
Maybe both your handles all skill coming up through high school or Will's handle, maybe both of your handles. The ball skill. Coming up through high school. Ball skill. Ball skill haze. Here he comes. I love not even commenting and just watching you sort of, sort of, deadly draw that one out.
可能你们俩都有这梗，高中时的球技，或者威尔的梗，可能你们俩都有。球技。高中时候练就的。球技。球技海斯。他来了。我就喜欢不作任何评论，就看着你慢条斯理地、死气沉沉地把这个梗抛出来。
And I think that's what you want, my other one of you. That's how I felt all day today, doing our, doing our, doing our sketches today. Yeah, we were working on something today and chatting about something today that's to come that we keep talking about. Not sure we got anything usable today. Yeah, we were working on something today and chatting about something today that's to come that we keep talking about. Not sure we got anything usable today. I think we did.
我想这就是你们俩想要的。我今天一整天做我们的——做我们的——做我们的素描时也是这种感觉。对，我们今天在做一些东西，今天还在聊一些即将推出的、我们一直挂在嘴边的东西。不确定今天有没有弄出什么能用的东西。对，我们今天在做一些东西，今天还在聊一些即将推出的、我们一直挂在嘴边的东西。不确定今天有没有弄出什么能用的东西。我想我们弄出来了。
Absolutely, oh please, JB, give me a break. Yeah, of course we did. Of course, of course, of course we did. And it's all in the vein of this fun thing that we keep talking about that we're really excited about. When are we gonna talk more about that? In a few weeks. Pretty soon.
绝对的，拜托，JB，饶了我吧。对，我们当然弄出来了。当然，当然，当然弄出来了。这完全符合我们一直在讨论的那个有趣的事情的调性，我们对此真的超级兴奋。我们什么时候能多聊聊那个？几周后。很快。
When is the audience ready to hear? In a matter of weeks, we're gonna be able to talk about what it really is, and I think it's exciting. I'm very excited to talk more about that. In a few weeks. Pretty soon. When is the audience ready to hear? In a matter of weeks, we're going to be able to talk about what it really is, and I think it's exciting. I'm very excited to share with our listeners. I'm excited too, super excited. I think it's something that they might like. They might use it. That's what else I'm excited about.
观众什么时候准备好听这个了？再过几周，我们就能讨论它到底是什么了，我觉得这很让人兴奋。我非常高兴能多聊聊这个。几周后。很快。观众什么时候准备好听这个了？再过几周，我们就能讨论它到底是什么了，我觉得这很让人兴奋。我非常高兴能与我们的听众分享。我也很兴奋，超级兴奋。我觉得这可能是他们会喜欢的东西。他们可能会用到它。这就是我同样兴奋的原因。
What is it, your next guest? Yes. This is what I like. I like his segue more than anything. A smooth segue. Will, have you figured it out yet? Because I was talking to Will, giving him clues today. I was trying to think, you were like, oh, it's so me. Give me a clue.
是什么，你的下一位嘉宾？对。我喜欢这个。我最喜欢他这一点，过渡得真丝滑。流畅的过渡。威尔，你猜出来了吗？因为我刚才在跟威尔说话，今天给他透了点线索。我当时在想，你当时说，哦，这太像我了。给个线索吧。
I'll figure it out, I'm brighter than him. Well, so I'll read it. You'll guess it by the end of this intro. Here we go. We'll have to add him to our smart list, legendary all-star list that I've kind of started. But dedicated to his craft, he trained with an Olympic fencer
我会猜出来的，我比他聪明。好吧，那我读一下。你会在这个开场结束前猜出来。我们开始吧。我们得把他加入我们的“聪明无能”传奇全明星名单里，这是我刚发起的一个名单。但他对自己的艺术非常专注，他曾跟一位奥运击剑手训练过
before becoming the thing I cannot yet mention. As a child, he often contemplated who he'd rather fly as, Superman or Peter Pan. His career started with a role in General Hospital, which primed him for the pilot of Eight is Enough. John Stamos. As he patiently awaited May 25th, 1977,
然后才成了那个我还不能透露的东西。小时候，他经常纠结自己更愿意变成超人还是彼得·潘飞行。他的职业生涯始于在《综合医院》中的一个角色，这为他出演《八个够》的试播集做好了准备。约翰·斯塔莫斯。当他耐心地等待着1977年5月25日的到来——
when the world would come to know him as one of the most famous heroes in cinematic history, that role's Luke Skywalker and he is Mark Hamill. Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! is Mark Hamill. Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!
那天，全世界都将认识他，他将成为电影史上最著名的英雄之一，那个角色就是卢克·天行者，他就是马克·哈米尔。哇！哇！哇！哇！哇！哇！就是马克·哈米尔。哇！哇！哇！哇！哇！
Whoa, Mr. Hamill. Now Sean, how are you even, at least you're sitting. I'm not even kidding. I'm shaking a little bit. Shaking a little bit. How'd you get through the day? Sorry, we're gonna give you in a second, Mr. Hamill. This guy, Sean Hayes, lives and breathes Star Wars.
哇，哈米尔先生。话说肖恩，你怎么还能——好歹你还坐着。我真没开玩笑。我有点发抖。有点发抖。你是怎么熬过这一天的？抱歉，我们马上让你说，哈米尔先生。这家伙，肖恩·海斯，满脑子都是《星球大战》。
He said, when you see my guest tonight, you're gonna be like, of course, that makes total sense. And I was like, who could it be? He's not the mayor of Tatooine, but it's close. It's close. So wait, just before we start, my first of all, thank you for being on here. This is huge for me and-
他说，当你今晚看到我的嘉宾时，你会觉得，理所当然，这完全说得通。然后我就在想，会是谁呢？他不是塔图因的市长，但也差不多了。差不多。所以等等，在我们开始之前，首先，非常感谢你能来。这对我和——
Thank you, all of us. Billions of other people. Oh my God. This guy's a national treasure for Christ's sake. You are, and I can't believe you're, but before we start, I just want to read to you what you wrote on your Instagram about Stephen King. You wrote, it took every ounce of discipline I possessed
谢谢，对我们所有人都一样。其他几十亿人也是。哦，天哪。这家伙简直是国宝，看在上帝的份上。你的确是，我简直不敢相信你——但在开始之前，我只想给你读读你在Instagram上关于斯蒂芬·金写的话。你写道：“我使出了浑身解数的自律，
to avoid freaking out and exposing myself as the weak need, slavish fanboy I truly am. And of course, I feel the same way about you as you wrote about Stephen King. Because I've been waiting 50 years to talk to you. Oh my God. This is crazy. This is so good.
才勉强克制住自己没有疯狂尖叫，没有暴露出我其实是个意志薄弱、奴颜婢膝的狂热粉丝的真面目。”当然，我对你的感觉就跟你对斯蒂芬·金的感觉一模一样。因为我已经等了50年想跟你聊聊了。哦，天哪。太疯狂了。太棒了。
It's crazy that I'm talking to you. Well it's not quite 50 years, it's 47. I mean let's be honest, because the movie came out in 77. I saw A New Hope four times in a row. I know I give Sean a lot of shit for being a Star Wars. I saw the first one four times in the theaters. I know I give Sean a lot of shit for being a Star Wars. I saw the first one four times in the theaters when I was a kid. Well, so you were all like 12, 13, 14.
能跟你说话感觉太疯狂了。好吧，其实还不到50年，是47年。说实话，因为电影是77年上映的。我连着看了四遍《新的希望》。我知道我经常拿肖恩当星战迷这事开玩笑。我小时候在电影院看了四遍第一部。我知道我经常拿肖恩当星战迷这事开玩笑。我小时候在电影院看了四遍第一部。好吧，所以你们当时大概12、13、14岁吧。
I was seven. We were both seven. Sean and I were both seven. They both look much older than I do. Well. Now, Will, did you pay four times for it, or did you just? Yeah, I went four times.
我七岁。我们俩都七岁。肖恩和我当时都七岁。他们俩看起来比我老多了。好吧。话说威尔，你当时看了四次都买票了吗，还是说你只是——对，我去了四次。
I went, yes, of course. Are you kidding? You left the theater and reentered four times. Nobody could believe it was a phenomenon, that nobody could believe it. It changed everything. And we were like. We talk about it all the time on this show,
我去了，是的，当然。开什么玩笑？你走出电影院又进去了四次。谁都不敢相信这会是一个轰动全球的现象，谁都不敢相信。它改变了一切。当时我们就觉得——我们在这个节目里经常聊到这个，
when we talk about movies. We do, we do talk. And I give Sean a lot of shit just for being a nerd, Mark. But that's not the only reason he's a nerd. He's a nerd for a lot of other reasons. Mark, how was it to continue being a part of that, going forward, on and on? Did you think it would go on this long? Oh, of course not. No, how was it to continue being a part of that going forward on and on? Did you think it would go on this long?
当我们聊到电影的时候。我们确实聊过。马克，我老拿肖恩是个书呆子开玩笑。但这并不是他唯一的书呆子原因。他因为很多其他原因也是个书呆子。马克，继续成为其中的一部分，一直以来，不断延续下去，感觉怎么样？你觉得这能持续这么久吗？哦，当然不。不，继续成为其中的一部分，一直以来，不断延续下去，感觉怎么样？你觉得这能持续这么久吗？
Oh, of course not. No, no, not at all. Although when we were doing it, I remember the first couple of days we shot in North Africa, I went over with Guinness and the Droids, and I hadn't met Carrier Harrison yet. And I said to George, why is this episode four? Why aren't you starting with episode one?
哦，当然不。不，不，一点也不。不过当我们拍摄的时候，我记得在北非拍的前几天，我和吉尼斯还有机器人一起过去的，我还没见过凯莉和哈里森。我问乔治，为什么这是第四部？你为什么不从第一部开始拍？
He goes, wow, wow, episode one, it's a lot of exposition and it's more political. This trilogy is much more commercial. So he knew. Did he already have plans that he would go back and do those first three? Or did he just kind of jettison that from the very beginning and just like,
他说，哇，哇，第一部有很多背景交代，而且更政治化。三部曲要商业化得多。所以他心里有数。他当时就已经计划好要回去拍前三部了吗？还是说他从一开始就把这个给抛弃了，就好像，
ah yeah, we're just gonna not even do those stories? Well, the way I understood it was that he originally planned four trilogies of 12, but when we were shooting, I asked him about the first trilogy and he explained, well this is more commercial, there's a lot of exposition and it's political and it's about taxation and blah, blah, blah,
啊，对，我们干脆连那些故事都不拍了？好吧，我的理解是，他最初计划的是四个三部曲，一共12部，但当我们拍摄时，我问过他关于第一部三部曲的事，他解释说，好吧，这个更商业化，里面有很多背景交代，而且很政治化，是关于收税之类七七八八的，
so I wanted to, he wanted you to feel like you walked into a serial chapter play and you'd missed the first few episodes. That's why they had the crawl to bring you up to speed. But I mean, as actors, you must appreciate this. When I auditioned, we just had a, it was an open cattle call, Brian De Palma was casting Stephen King's Carrie, the horror movie set in high school, and George was casting Star Wars,
所以我想让你感觉就像是走入了一部连载章节剧，而你错过了前几集。这就是为什么要有开场滚动字幕来让你了解背景。但我的意思是，作为演员，你们一定能体会到这一点。当我试镜时，我们只是有一个——那是一次公开的海选，布赖恩·德·帕玛正在为斯蒂芬·金的《魔女嘉莉》（那部以高中为背景的恐怖电影）选角，乔治则在为《星球大战》选角，
and it was a cattle call. Like I say, you sat down, they said, tell us a little about yourself, and you talked for five minutes, and they said thank you. They didn't talk about the project at all. But here's the interesting part. My agent says, okay, you've got a screen test. We're sending you the page. It was like a 10 page scene with Harrison as Han Solo
那是一次海选。就像我说的，你坐下，他们说，跟我们聊聊你自己吧，然后你聊了五分钟，他们就说谢谢。他们压根没谈这个项目。但有趣的部分来了。我的经纪人说，好吧，你要去试镜了。他们会把剧页发给你。那是一个大约10页的场景，有哈里森饰演的韩·索罗，
in the cockpit of the Millennium Falcon. No Wookie, just the two of us. But there was no context. I'm reading this thing going, wait a second, is this like a parody or a send up of Flash Gordon, is it like Mel Brooks or whatever, so when I went to the audition, I went to Harrison because he had done American Graffiti, he'd known George, and I said, Harrison, is this like a send up, I mean, is it, he said, hey kid, let's just get it done.
在千年隼号的驾驶舱里。没有楚巴卡，只有我们俩。但没有任何背景。我读着这玩意儿心想，等一下，这到底是个恶搞，还是在模仿《飞侠哥顿》？是像梅尔·布鲁克斯那种风格吗？所以当我去试镜时，我去找了哈里森，因为他演过《美国风情画》，认识乔治，我说，哈里森，这到底是不是个恶搞，我是说，它是吗？他说，嘿，孩子，赶紧把它演完就得了。
You know, he was absolutely no help whatsoever. I could listen to you imitate him all day. So was he, did he have to audition at all or was he, he was already set in that part coming off of American Graffiti? Well no, he'd already done American Graffiti. When I did the screen test, I don't know whether he was set or not,
你知道，他简直一点忙都没帮。我能听你模仿他一整天。所以他当时需要试镜吗？还是说他凭借《美国风情画》的余热已经定下了这个角色？哦，不，他已经演过《美国风情画》了。我试镜的时候，我不知道他定下来没有，
but he did do a screen test with Carrie, so I guess George was fairly sure. And there were two sets of three. And Marsha Lucas, George's wife said, when he was packing to go to London, he hadn't decided between the two. I mean, there was no mix and match. It was me, Harrison and Kerry, or Will Seltzer, Terry Nunn,
但他确实和嘉莉一起试镜了，所以我想乔治当时相当确定。当时有两组三人组合。乔治的妻子玛莎·卢卡斯说，当他打包要去伦敦时，他还没在两组之间做出决定。我的意思是，根本没有混搭。当时是我、哈里森和凯莉，或者威尔·塞尔策、特里·南，
and I forget now who's Han Solo. And she took credit. She said, I'm the one that suggested he go with you guys. That's great. That's amazing. But here's what's so interesting is, and I went to George at the same audition, said the same thing I said to Harrison.
我记不清另一个韩·索罗是谁了。然后她居功至伟。她说，是我建议他选你们这几个人的。太棒了。太神奇了。但最有趣的是，我在同一次试镜中去找乔治，问了跟对哈里森说一样的话。
Is this like a parody or a re-series? He went, let's just do it and we'll talk about it later. Translation, translation, let's just do it and we'll never talk about it later. Sure, sure. Shut up and hit your mark. Exactly. Translation, translation, let's just do it and we'll never talk about it later. Shut up and hit your mark. Exactly, George is not like, he's not an actor's director. He comes alive in the editing room.
这到底是个恶搞还是个续集剧？他说，先拍了再说，以后再谈。翻译过来就是，翻译过来就是，先拍了再说，以后再也别谈了。没错，没错。闭嘴，找好你的位置。没错，翻译过来就是，翻译过来就是，先拍了再说，以后再也别谈了。闭嘴，找好你的位置。没错，乔治才不是那种——他可不是那种导演演员的导演。他在剪辑室里才真正活过来。
He doesn't want to hear about backstory or motivation or whatever. Now Irvin Kirchner was the opposite. He was very much into that. He did Empire. But like I say, the moment my agent said, okay, you got it, and they're sending the script over, I will never forget reading that script for the first time
他才不想听什么背景故事、动机之类的话。而欧文·柯什纳则截然相反。他对那些非常感兴趣。他执导了《帝国反击战》。但就像我说的，我经纪人一说，好吧，你拿下了，他们正把剧本送过来，我永远不会忘记第一次读那个剧本的情景，
because it just blew my mind. I mean, even without John Williams' music, or the special effects, yes, it was all on the page, you guys, you really got the sense of. Isn't that amazing? Yes, it was. What about you realizing what part you had just gotten to? That's it.
因为我的大脑直接被炸裂了。我的意思是，甚至都没有约翰·威廉姆斯的音乐，也没有特效，是的，全都在纸面上，伙计们，你们真的能感受到那种——是不是很神奇？是的，确实如此。那你意识到自己刚拿到的是个什么角色时呢？就是这样。
I have to tell you, Jason, when I, it was weeks, maybe a month later, and when I tested, I figured, oh, Harrison's the leading man. I'm like the annoying sidekick, right? Because I'm badgering him and all this stuff. And I have to do this for you. I mean, my daughter has heard this a million times. There was a line in the screen test
我得告诉你，杰森，当我在——那是几个星期后，也许是一个月后，当我试镜时，我想，哦，哈里森是男主角。我就像是个烦人的跟班，对吧？因为我一直在纠缠他，诸如此类。我得为你表演一下这个。我的意思是，我女儿已经听过这个一百万遍了。试镜的时候有一句台词，
that thankfully was not in the finished product. We're going towards the Death Star, and Solo says basically, look, I've done my part. When we get to an inhabitable asteroid, I'm jumping you and the droids off. And here's my actual line. But we can't turn back. Fear is their greatest defense.
谢天谢地，最后成品里没有。我们要飞向死星，索罗基本上说，听着，我的部分完成了。当我们到达一颗适宜居住的小行星时，我和机器人就要跳机了。这是我的真实台词：“但我们不能回头。恐惧是他们最大的防线。
I doubt if the actual security there is any greater than it was on Aquali or Solace, and what there is is most likely directed towards a large-scale assault. Ah! Now, try and make that sound like it's a spontaneous thought just coming off the top of your head. And I mean, you could diagram this sentence. Well, whenever Scotty and I run out to the store,
我怀疑那里的实际安全防备并不比阿奎利或索拉斯星强多少，而那里的防备多半是针对大规模袭击的。”啊！现在，试着把它说得像是一个脱口而出、自然而然的想法。我的意思是，你甚至可以把这个句子画出语法结构图。好吧，每当斯科蒂和我跑去商店时，
we say, but I was going in a Tosche station to pick up some power converters. Which, here it is. I was going in a Tosche station to pick up some power converters. Which, here it is. Here it is. I was going in a Tosche station to pick up some power converters. There he is. And people don't believe me, but I was trying to be as whiny baby as I could so I had somewhere to go. Yeah, yeah, yeah. For sure.
我们就会说：“但我本来是要去托什站买一些动力转换器的。”就是这个。我本来是要去托什站买一些动力转换器的。就是这个。就是这个。我本来是要去托什站买一些动力转换器的。就是他。人们不相信我，但我当时尽量表现得像个爱哭鬼，这样我才有发挥的空间。对，对，对。肯定的。
Yeah, you had to be this kid who did it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And you got to be as annoying and whiny as possible, but I still get garbage over that over the years. Because I just watched, I didn't even tell you this, Sean, I just watched A New Hope again recently with the little kids, with my kids, and it just holds up in the most crazy. How old is it?
对，你得演那个这么干的孩子。对，对，对。你得尽可能表现得讨厌和爱哭，不过这些年来我为此还是没少挨损。因为我刚看了一遍——我甚至都没告诉你这个，肖恩——我最近又和几个小家伙、和我的孩子们一起看了一遍《新的希望》，它依然经受住了时间的考验，简直疯狂。它有多久了？
What is it? 1977? He shot it in 76 and it came out in 77. You guys shot it in 76 and it came out in 77. You guys shot it in seven, you shot it in 76. It's 48 years, man. Yeah, I was 24. Almost 49. Wow.
是多少年？1977年？他在76年拍摄，77年上映的。你们在76年拍摄，77年上映的。你们在——你们在76年拍摄的。48年了，老兄。对，我当时24岁。快49岁了。哇。
So you shoot that thing in 1976 in London and in North Africa. Right. Right. And I remember, by the way, I remember my friend, this guy I worked with, Peter Cohn, who was a first assistant director on lots of big movies. But one of his first jobs, he was a PA, right,
所以你们在1976年的伦敦和北非拍摄那部电影。没错。没错。顺便说一句，我记得我的朋友，这个跟我合作过的家伙，彼得·科恩，他曾是许多大片的第一副导演。但他的第一份工作之一，他是个制片助理，对吧，
on A New Hope, Peter was? Yes, and the thing was, he was not gonna be able to go to, they weren't taking him to North Africa, but when they discovered he spoke French, he was in. And he was like 19 19 and we became fast friends and he's still one of my closest friends today. Wow, I love that. He's a great guy.
在《新的希望》剧组，彼得是吗？是的，当时的情况是，他本来去不了北非，他们不带他去北非，但当他们发现他会说法语时，他就入选了。他当时大概19岁，19岁，然后我们成了形影不离的好朋友，直到今天他依然是我最要好的朋友之一。哇，我喜欢这个。他是个好人。
And I worked with him on a couple movies. He was the first AD on Blades of Glory. He was also first AD on With Nail and I, which is my favorite film of all time. Yes, yes, yes, great. So, but I remember him telling me, and maybe Mark, you can speak to this, telling me about like, for instance,
我和他在几部电影里合作过。他是《冰刀双人组》的第一副导演。他还是《我与长指甲》（Withnail and I）的第一副导演，那是我有史以来最喜欢的电影。没错，没错，没错，太棒了。所以，但我记得他告诉我，马克，也许你能说一说，他告诉我，比如说，
R2-D2 was just like this, because it was 1976, it was just like this bucket, like this metallic, and it would fall over, they'd kick it. Yes, yes, exactly. It's a marvel of editing because- Sean, why are you crying? Sean, I'm on the verge. On the verge. No, but kidding. I'm on the verge.
R2-D2当时就像是——因为那是1976年，它就像是个水桶，金属的桶，总是摔倒，他们还踢它。是的，没错，没错。这简直是剪辑上的奇迹，因为——肖恩，你为什么在哭？肖恩，我快哭了。边缘。不，但开玩笑的。我快哭了。
No, but tell us. Well, no, it was like you say, I mean, George called it the most expensive, low budget movie ever made. Yeah. Right. And what he meant by that was every single penny has to be up on the screen. The only people they actually had to pay decent salaries to
不，但跟我们讲讲。好吧，不，就像你说的，乔治管它叫拍过的最昂贵的低成本电影。对。没错。他的意思是，每一分钱都必须花在银幕上。他们唯一必须支付可观薪水的演员
would be Alec Guinness and Peter Cushing. All of us were unknowns. I think I got a thousand a week. I remember complaining to my agent, whoa, I make 8,000 to 10,000 on television a week. And she said, hey, get a grip. It's a movie, it's George Lucas, it's Alan Guinness. I went, oh yeah.
也就是亚历克·吉尼斯和彼得·库欣。我们所有人都是默默无闻的新人。我想我当时的片酬是一周一千块。我记得我还跟经纪人抱怨过，哇，我在电视上拍一周能赚8,000到10,000呢。她说，嘿，清醒点吧。这是一部电影，这是乔治·卢卡斯，这是亚历克·吉尼斯。我说，哦，好吧。
And as you know, I mean, money is secondary. We do this because we love it. And if you can get a nice salary, good for you. But wait, what about Robert Englund? For my sister Tracy, Robert Englund was Freddie Krueger. And he told you to audition for Star Wars? Is that true? Well, in his book, he said,
如你们所知，钱是次要的。我们做这个是因为我们热爱它。如果你能拿到不错的薪水，那很好。但等等，罗伯特·英格兰呢？对于我姐姐特雷西来说，罗伯特·英格兰就是弗莱迪·克鲁格。他让你去试镜《星球大战》？真的吗？好吧，在他的书里，他说，
basically if it weren't for me, Mark wouldn't be Luke Skywalker. To be fair, I mean, I love Robert. But when he said that to me, he had just come back from an audition. You know how it is. Once you've auditioned, you feel free to tell your friends, oh, have you been out for this thing?
基本上如果没有他，马克就不会成为卢克·天行者。公平地说，我爱罗伯特。但当他跟我这么说的时候，他刚刚结束了一场试镜。你知道的。一旦你试镜完了，你就可以自由地告诉朋友们，“哦，你去试镜那个项目了吗？”
And he said, have you been out for this George Lucas thing? And I said, no. And I went to the phone, I called my agent, and I told her about it, and she said, I'm all over it, you've got an appointment next Wednesday. So I hate to burst Robert's bubble. And it makes for a better story. Sure, it's a good sound bite,
他说，“你去了乔治·卢卡斯的那个项目吗？”我说，“没有。”然后我拿起电话，打给我的经纪人，把这事告诉了她，她说，“我全权搞定，你下周三有个面试。”所以我很抱歉打破罗伯特的幻想。这让故事听起来更好。当然，这是一个很好的宣传噱头，
but you know what, we've put it to rest now and fucking. Yeah, yeah. I'm just kidding, I was about to unload. I don't know the guy at all, it's great. Were you, what was your work schedule like before Star Wars? Were you- Yeah, you were in the pilot of Eight Is Enough.
但你知道吗，我们现在已经把这事放下了，他妈的——对，对。我开玩笑的，我刚才差点发飙。我根本不认识这家伙，这太棒了。你拍《星球大战》之前的工作日程是怎样的？你是——对，你演了《八个够》的试播集。
That's what I want to know. And then you got replaced. But they changed a lot of the people in the pilot. They changed the father. They changed three siblings, including me. Vic Van Patten. I was just doing, you know, I did TV, after The Soap, I did TV movies.
这就是我想知道的。然后你被换掉了。但他们在试播集里换了很多人。他们换了父亲。他们换了三个兄弟姐妹，包括我。维克·范·帕顿。我当时只是在拍——你知道的，演完《肥皂剧》后，我拍了电视电影。
I don't know how many, 30 or something, between 70 and 76 and lots and lots of, you know, FBI. You were a working actor. This wasn't a huge shock to you, to the system when this thing took off. I mean, I guess how can you be prepared for that kind of exposure? You can.
我不知道拍了多少部，30部左右吧，在70年到76年之间，拍了超级多的《联邦调查局》之类的。你是个高产的演员。当这东西腾飞时，对你来说这并不是对整个系统的巨大冲击。我的意思是，你怎么可能对那种曝光度有所准备呢？你根本做不到。
But it wasn't, you weren't right off a truck. No, no, no. And the way I felt about it, I thought, that kind of exposure, but you weren't right off a truck. No, no, no. Right. And the way I felt about it, I thought, I didn't see any ads for it on television. Like, I'd watch Saturday Night Live, and usually they'd place a movie, commercials there,
但这并不是——你不是刚进城的乡巴佬。不，不，不。我当时的感受是，那种曝光度，但你并不是刚进城的乡巴佬。不，不，不。没错。我当时的感受是，我当时在电视上没看到任何广告。比如，我看《周六夜现场》，通常他们会在那里插播电影广告，
I didn't see it. And on the day it opened, the driver picked me up to go dub the 35 millimeter prints, because it only opened in like 16 theaters in 70 millimeter. And I said, can you drive by Gromit's Chinese? I want to see what it looks like up on the marquee. Oh, here's a fun fact. There was such disagreement on how to promote it at Fox
我当时没看到。上映那天，司机接我去给35毫米拷贝配音，因为它当时只在大概16家影院以70毫米格式上映。我说，你能开车从格劳曼中国剧院路过吗？我想看看它在巨幅海报上长什么样。哦，这里有个有趣的八卦。福斯内部对于如何宣传这部电影存在巨大的分歧，
that it opened with no poster. No. Wow, that's crazy. They just stapled the lobby cards up because they couldn't, is this like, one faction was promoting it like an entertainment journey beyond your imagination, far beyond. The other one was like pushing the more comedic aspects,
以至于上映时连海报都没有。没有。哇，太疯狂了。他们只是把大堂宣传画钉在墙上，因为他们无法决定——一种派系把它宣传为一次超越你想象的娱乐之旅，超越一切。另一派则在推销更多喜剧元素，
you know, little rascals in outer space. But they couldn't agree. So anyway, I said, can you drive by Grammas? And now what I thought was, this thing's gonna take a couple of weeks to get going, because the hardcore sci-fi, fantasy, horror fans are all gonna see it on day one, but it'll take word of mouth for it to spread and say,
你知道的，外太空的小淘气。但他们无法达成一致。所以不管怎样，我说，能从格劳曼路过吗？当时我想的是，这东西可能需要几个星期才能发酵，因为核心的科幻、奇幻、恐怖迷们会在第一天全都去看，但要靠口碑传播开来需要时间，大家会说，
hey, you know what, it's pretty funny too, and it's all these things. But so anyway, we drove by, and I couldn't believe my eyes, there were lines around the block the first day, so I couldn't figure it out. Yeah, what was the promotion that got that amount of interest going? I was too young to really notice it,
嘿，你知道吗，其实挺逗的，还有诸如此类的好处。但无论如何，我们开车路过时，我简直不敢相信自己的眼睛，第一天影院外就排起了长龙，所以我完全想不通。对，是什么宣传引发了那么高的关注度？我当时太年轻了，没太注意到，
but how do you think they accrued that much interest in it without the posters instead of the commercials? Well, they did a poster, I think Hildebrand was the artist, and they depicted Luke as like 6'2", and ripped with muscles and a whole thing. Didn't look anything like me. And I didn't even audition, but yeah.
但你觉得他们在没有海报、没有商业广告的情况下，是怎么积攒起那么多关注度的呢？好吧，他们做过一张海报，我想希尔德布兰德是艺术家，他把卢克描绘得像是个身高6尺2寸、肌肉线条分明、健美无比的硬汉。跟我长得一点都不像。我甚至都没试镜，不过对。
You know what's funny though, what a great example, once again, of how fucking lucky the suits got. Oh yeah. And they kind of got in their own way and couldn't agree on a poster who were so quick to rush to take credit for shit and blah, blah, blah.
但你知道最搞笑的是什么吗，这又是一个完美的例子，证明了这群高管走了什么狗屎运。哦，对。他们总是碍手碍脚，甚至连一张海报都无法达成一致，却又如此急功近利地抢占功劳，废话连篇。
And I know that- But it was the merits of it that gave it its likes. And it was the merits of the picture itself, they got it to where and created this thing. And how quickly do you think, Mark, those same people who decided that they couldn't figure out to put a fucking poster out or whatever, how quickly do you think they took credit at dinner
我知道——但正是电影本身的质量赋予了它热度。正是影片本身的品质，才把它推到了这个高度并创造了这一切。马克，你觉得那些决定不发海报之类的家伙，在当晚的晚餐或第二周的午餐上，跟别人吹嘘邀功的速度有多快？这他妈太荒谬了。
that night or the next week or at a lunch with other, it's fucking absurd. Isn't that the way, cause they really didn't see any potential and they were, you know, we didn't, Of course, of course they did. They were really prepared to dump it, but you know George had made a graffiti at Universal, and the head of Universal wanted to dump it on the second half of a double bill.
难道不是吗，因为他们根本没看到任何潜力，而且他们——你知道的，我们没有——当然，当然他们会。他们本来都准备好把它当垃圾扔掉了，但你知道乔治曾在环球影业拍过《美国风情画》，环球影业的负责人本想把它当成双片连映的下半场烂片给扔掉。
And it was only Francis Ford Coppola that went to him and said, look, you've got to give this a chance because they were mad because they spent so much money to get the rights to all the music, all the vintage rock and roll. But to think that American graffiti could have been just thrown away, and they never learned. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
正是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉去找他，说，“听着，你必须给它一次机会”，因为他们当时气坏了，他们花了大笔钱买下所有音乐、所有复古摇滚乐的版权。但一想到《美国风情画》本可能被直接扔掉，而他们却永远学不乖。对。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。
Hey, what had John Williams done before? He did Jaws before this, yes. Oh my God, he did so much. No, but before Jaws or this. yes. Oh my God, he did so much. No, but before Jaws or this. He did Lost in Space, he did... He was billed as Johnny Williams and he did a lot of universal television shows. I mean, we were so... He did Gilligan's Island.
嘿，约翰·威廉姆斯之前做过什么？他在此之前做过《大白鲨》，是的。哦，天哪，他做过太多了。不，但在《大白鲨》或这个之前。是的。哦，天哪，他做过太多了。不，但在《大白鲨》或这个之前。他做过《迷失太空》，他做过——他当时署名为约翰尼·威廉姆斯，制作了许多环球电视台的节目。我的意思是，我们太——他做过《吉里根岛》。
Aside from George, I think he's probably more responsible for the success of that film than any other single person. Because when I remember Gary Kirsch, the producer, picked me up to go to another dubbing session. He said, oh, I just got the score from, I was over in London with a little, when he put it on, you guys, I'm telling you, I felt tears streaming down my face.
除了乔治之外，我认为他对这部电影成功的贡献可能比其他任何单个人都要大。因为我记得制片人加里·柯希施接我去另一个配音场时，他说，“哦，我刚拿到配乐，”他之前在伦敦跟一个小乐队——当他放给我们听时，伙计们，我告诉你们，我感觉眼泪顺着脸颊流了下来。
I just couldn't, exactly. I also wanted to finish the story about me reading it for the first time. Remember, I got it without reading a script. I just had read that one. Sorry, keep going, yeah. Well, here's the thing. When I opened to the first page,
我简直——完全如此。我还想讲完我第一次读剧本的故事。记住，我是没看剧本就接下了这个角色。我只读了那一页。抱歉，你继续，对。好吧，事情是这样的。当我翻开第一页时，
it said, the adventures of Luke Starkiller as taken from the Journal of the Will's, Saga number one, the Star Wars. Will's, Saga No. 1, The Star Wars. And I'm thinking, wait a minute, wasn't I Luke? No, I guess Harrison was Luke because I figured he was a traditional leading man. He was 35 or whatever and he was Harrison Ford. Come on.
上面写着：“卢克·斯塔克杀手的冒险，取自威尔氏日记，传奇第一部，星战。”威尔氏日记，传奇第一部，星战。我在想，等等，难道我不叫卢克吗？不，我猜哈里森才是卢克，因为我想他是个传统的男主角。他当时35岁左右，而且他是哈里森·福特。拜托。
So I started to read this thing and in the very beginning I realized, oh my God, this is seen through the eyes of this teenage farm boy. I mean, that was unusual in and of itself. You'd think it'd probably be through the eyes of Han Solo, but I mean, that's the journey that... Give us a little bit of Harrison's reaction when he read the script. If I want that now.
所以我开始读这东西，在一开始我意识到，哦，天哪，这是通过这个十几岁的农场少年的视角来看的。我的意思是，这本身就很不寻常。你会觉得它可能是通过韩·索罗的视角，但我的意思是，这段旅程——给我们讲讲哈里森读到剧本时的反应吧。我现在就想知道。
By the way, Sean, I have to tell you, after I didn't say, oh, I'm going to go do an impression of Harrison Ford, I was on Seth Meyers, and I was just relaying a story that happened to us when we were on the Death Star. We were midday, and I said, wait a second, this scene takes place after we were in the trash compactor, which we hadn't filmed yet.
顺便说一句，肖恩，我必须告诉你，在我没有说“哦，我要去模仿一下哈里森·福特”之前，我上了赛斯·迈尔斯的节目，我只是在讲述我们在死星上时发生的一个故事。当时正值中午，我说，“等一下，这个场景发生在我们进入垃圾压缩机之后，而我们当时还没拍呢。”
Or maybe we had, because I said, shouldn't I have like some schmutz and messy hair and polystyrene in my hair? And he goes, hey kid, it ain't that kind of movie. If anybody's looking at your hair, we're all in big trouble. And I went, boy, is he right. He's so right. You know, I told him, I said, you know,
或者也许我们已经拍了，因为我说，“我是不是应该沾点污垢，头发乱蓬蓬的，头上还挂着聚苯乙烯泡沫？”然后他说，“嘿，孩子，这不是那种电影。如果有人在盯着你的头发看，那我们全都要完蛋。”然后我想，天哪，他说得太对了。他太对了。你知道，我告诉他，我说，“你知道吗，
you really make a great director if you weren't so lazy. Because he knows his part and he knows everybody and he'll give you suggestions, they're all gold. I just idolized him. I mean, when he walked in the door the first time, because I went back after he did the stuff in Africa, Harrison came first and he comes on the soundstage in his Han Solo gear,
如果你没那么懒的话，你其实是个绝佳的导演。”因为他很懂自己的角色，也很懂每个人，他给你的建议全都是金玉良言。我简直太崇拜他了。我的意思是，当他第一次走进门时——因为我在他在非洲拍完戏回来后又回去了，哈里森先来的，他穿着韩·索罗的行头走进录音棚，
and I just, I already liked him in the conversation and American Graffiti anyway, but I mean, I just was, the relationship was real because I idolized him, I looked at him as a mentor, an older brother and all that. So I loved that. He was so fucking cool with the vest and shit. Yeah, and when I read it I thought, oh my God, why don't I ever get the part
我当时就——我在之前的谈话中就已经挺喜欢他了，而且还有《美国风情画》什么的，但我的意思是，这种关系是真实的，因为我崇拜他，我把他看作导师、老大哥之类的人物。所以我很喜欢他。他穿着背心什么的，简直帅呆了。对，当我读到的时候我想，哦，天哪，为什么我从来没有机会演
of the womanizing gambler and scoundrel, you know? I'm just like, oh, I'm going to Toshi's station. What? I did a thing for Vanity Fair once and they said you can do any sort of character from a film, blah, blah, blah, and I went as Harrison Ford from Star Wars. Oh wow. Because I was like, yeah, he was a, and I went as Harrison Ford from Star Wars. Oh wow.
那个拈花惹草的赌徒和恶棍呢？我当时就想，哦，我要去托什站了。什么？我曾为《名利场》拍过一次照，他们说你可以扮演电影里的任何角色，巴拉巴拉，我扮演的就是《星球大战》里的哈里森·福特。哦，哇。因为我想，对啊，他是个——我扮演的就是《星球大战》里的星球大战里的哈里森·福特。哦，哇。
Because I was like, yeah, he was a cowboy. You know what I mean? Speaking of that, you must know, Mark, that these guys know Scotty, my husband, is as big a fan as I am. I mean, we've, you know. How far off camera is he right now? He might be coming on right this second.
因为我想，对啊，他是个牛仔。你知道我的意思吗？说起这个，马克，你一定知道，这几位都知道我的丈夫斯科蒂，他跟我一样是个超级大粉丝。我的意思是，我们——他现在离镜头有多远？他可能现在就要出镜了。
Oh good. Because he has a couple. Oh boy. He's dressed as Kylo Ren. Dressed as Kylo Ren. I mean, it doesn't get nerdier. We've got Scotty in the Kylo Ren. More royalties for George Lucas.
哦，太好了。因为他带了好几个。哦，天哪。他打扮成了凯洛·伦。打扮成了凯洛·伦。我的意思是，没有比这更书呆子气的了。我们有打扮成凯洛·伦的斯科蒂。给乔治·卢卡斯贡献更多版权费。
Very good. So Scotty's got like a couple. Hi, Scott. He's been waiting. I've been sitting here for like an hour. Just waiting. You know, my mom told me, she said, when you were born, I couldn't decide on a name.
非常好。所以斯科蒂带了几个——嗨，斯科特。他一直在等。我在这里坐了大概有一个小时了。就这么等着。你知道的，我妈妈告诉我，她说，当你出生时，我拿不定主意该叫什么名字。
It was between Mark and Scott. And they said, if you don't decide right now, we're just going to put baby Hamill on the birth certificate. So she literally flipped a coin. And of course, when she tells you that at age seven, you go, oh, Scott's so much a cooler name. You should have named him Scott. You always want what you don't have, right?
当时在马克和斯科特之间犹豫。他们说，如果你现在不做决定，我们就在出生证明上直接写“哈里森宝宝”了。所以她真的抛硬币决定的。当然，当你在七岁时听到这个故事，你会觉得，哦，斯科特这个名字酷多了。你应该给他取名叫斯科特。你总是想要你没有的东西，对吧？
But Scott, I'm a big fan, but Scottie's like a mega, mega fan. All right, go with Scottie. And he's got a couple questions. I know. It's next level. Hang on, first of all, welcome to Smartless, Scottie. Yeah, I think this is Scottie's debut, isn't it?
但斯科特，我是你的超级粉丝，但斯科蒂是个狂热、狂热的粉丝。好吧，让斯科蒂来吧。他有几个问题。我知道。这可是高水平的。等等，首先，欢迎来到《聪明无能》，斯科蒂。对，我想这是斯科蒂的处女秀吧？
I think it's your debut. It kind of is. On the proper podcast. On the proper podcast. On the proper podcast. I may have been seen in the background, but that's a no-go. Hi. Very good. Mark, it's such an honor to meet you.
我想这是你的处女秀。差不多是的。在正经的播客上。在正经的播客上。在正经的播客上。我可能在背景里露过面，但那不算数。嗨。非常好。马克，很荣幸能见到你。
Thank you. It goes without saying, I'm such a huge fan. But I think my question really is, at what point when everything was done, the film was done, it was completed, and it was about to come out, and all of that, done, the film was done, it was completed, and it was about to come out and all of that, I know the typical question is, did you know it was going to be a hit? Of course, nobody knows it's going to be a hit.
谢谢。不言而喻，我是你巨大的粉丝。但我想我的问题其实是，当一切都结束时，电影拍完了，完成了，马上就要上映了，所有这些都完成了，电影拍完了，完成了，马上就要上映了，所有这些——我知道典型的问题是，你当时知道它会大火吗？当然，没人会知道它会大火。
Anything's going to be a hit. It's not up to us. But when did you have that visceral sort of reaction like we all had, or did you ever have it like audiences had where you realized, oh, this is something bigger than all of us. This is unbelievable. There was a moment and it was,
任何事情能不能火都不是由我们决定的。但你是什么时候产生那种我们都有的本能反应，或者说你有没有像观众那样，意识到“哦，这比我们所有人都要宏大，这太不可思议了”？当时确实有个时刻，那是——
they sent the three of us, Carrie, Harrison and me to promote it. And we did Vancouver, I don't think it had opened. And then it opened and when we came into Chicago, I looked outside the plane and I saw massive crowds and I said, hey you guys, there's somebody famous on this plane. We were looking around to see if there was a big sports star or whatever, and then as we got closer,
他们把我们三个——凯莉、哈里森和我派去宣传。我们在温哥华，当时好像还没上映。然后它上映了，当我们飞抵芝加哥时，我向机舱外望去，看到乌压压的人群，我说，“嘿，伙计们，这飞机上肯定坐了个大明星。”我们四处张望，想看看是不是有什么体育巨星之类的，然后当我们离得更近时，
said hey, Carrie, look, that girl has buns on. She's got the Princess Leiba, Harrison, that guy's got the vest and everything. Somebody had made a Luke Tunic out of a pillow because there were people dressed like us and we all looked at each other like, whoa, that's above and beyond. I mean, you want it to be a successful movie,
我说，“嘿，凯莉，看，那个女孩头上顶着两个包子。她梳着莱娅公主的发型，哈里森，那个家伙穿着背心和全套装备。”有人用枕头做了一个卢克的束腰外衣，因为有好多人打扮得跟我们一模一样，我们面面相觑，心想，哇，这真是超乎想象。我的意思是，你当然希望电影能大获成功，
but when you see people then role playing. Especially 50 years later, right? I mean, it's like, hey, like a grown man. Go ahead, next question, Scottie. Listen, I'm here to give Sean a break from the harassment. It's now for me. Well, listen, I have to tell you, it's a double-edged sword because what'll happen is,
但当你看到人们开始进行角色扮演时——特别是50年后的今天，对吧？我的意思是，这就好比，嘿，就像一个成年人。请继续，下一个问题，斯科蒂。听着，我是来帮肖恩分担一点骚扰的。现在轮到我了。好吧，听着，我得告诉你，这是一把双刃剑，因为会发生的情况是——
and this has been happening for 20, 30 years, the kids that were little when it came out are now parents of their own, and you'll be in an airport or something. And you know, a five or six year old, they think we made Star Wars two weeks ago. I mean, there's nothing to really date it in terms of models of cars or clothing or whatever.
而且这种情况已经持续了20、30年了，当年上映时还是小屁孩的那些人现在自己都成了父母，你会身处机场之类的公共场所。你知道的，一个五六岁的小孩，他们以为我们是两周前才拍的《星球大战》。我的意思是，从汽车型号、服装或者其他任何方面来看，里面根本没有什么年代标记。
So they have no concept of time. And so they'll be, you know, the parents will gesture to a 55 year old me and go, hey kids, look who it is, it's Luke Skywalker. And they look at this, look at me in horror. Like God, what happened to this guy? He really let himself go. Great makeup artist in the movie.
所以他们对时间根本没有概念。所以他们会——你知道的，父母会指着55岁的我说，“嘿，孩子们，看那是谁，那是卢克·天行者。”然后他们看着这个——满脸惊恐地看着我。就像天哪，这家伙怎么搞成这样？他真的彻底放飞自我了。电影里的化妆师真厉害。
Yeah, exactly. So wait, so Scotty, do you have another question before you take off? Oh, Jesus Christ. No, I didn't realize I'd be by people on. No, you can hang out. I didn't know if you wanted to. No, no, no. No, I would love to. Oh, hang on, hang on, Jesus Christ. No, I didn't realize I'd be by people on- No, you can hang out. I didn't know if you wanted to. No, no, no.
对，完全如此。所以等等，斯科蒂，在你闪人之前还有别的问题吗？哦，耶稣基督。不，我没想到自己会出现在镜头前——不，你可以留下来。我不知道你是不是想——不，不，不。不，我很乐意。哦，等等，等等，耶稣基督。不，我没想到自己会出现在镜头前——不，你可以留下来。我不知道你是不是想——不，不，不。
No, I would love to. Oh, hang on, hang on, hang on. Hang on, hang on one second. Let me just say, Scottie, Scottie, I don't think that Sean meant that. I think that what he meant to say, like he didn't know if you had more, Sean, I got this, and then Sean, Sean,
不，我很乐意。哦，等等，等等，等等。等等，等一下。我只想说，斯科蒂，斯科蒂，我觉得肖恩不是那个意思。我觉得他想说的是，他不知道你还有没有更多——肖恩，我来搞定这个，然后肖恩，肖恩——
look at Scottie and tell him what you meant to say. Well, what I meant to say was, I didn't know if you had to go somewhere and I didn't want to keep you on the podcast. Where the fuck does he have to go? Be honest. I mean, what are you talking about? This is great.
看着斯科蒂，告诉他你本来想说什么。好吧，我本来想说的是，我不知道你是不是得去什么地方，我不想一直把你留在播客里。他他妈的能去哪儿？说实话。我是说，你在说什么呢？这太棒了。
Now Scott, how are you feeling? No, no, look at Sean and you tell him how you're feeling. Oh, I'm feeling wonderful and thank you for the opportunity. This is great. It's a pleasure to be here and I... Well, our hour is up. I'm glad that Mark could be here
现在，斯科特，你感觉怎么样？不，不，看着肖恩，告诉他你的感觉。哦，我感觉好极了，谢谢你给我这个机会。这太棒了。很高兴能来到这里，我……好吧，我们的一小时到了。我很高兴马克能来
for the two of the biggest Star Wars fans in the world, that Mark, you could see them work out. In couples therapy. In couples therapy. We owe everything to the fans. If it weren't for them, we wouldn't be anywhere. Right, right, right. Wait, Scott, you got it, you, Scott,
为了世界上两个最大的《星球大战》粉丝，马克，你能看着他们解决问题。在夫妻治疗中。在夫妻治疗中。我们的一切都归功于粉丝。如果没有他们，我们什么都不是。对，对，对。等等，斯科特，你懂的，你，斯科特，
you have to have one last burning desire question. Yeah, something. What about the, what about Norway with the Empire Strikes Back and the snow? Remember we were talking about that? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Wasn't there, I could have this wrong, but wasn't there a thing where you guys were, where you were in Norway,
你必须问最后一个最迫切的问题。对，随便什么。那什么，关于《帝国反击还》和挪威的雪呢？还记得我们谈过这个吗？哦，对，对，对。是不是有这么个事——我可能会记错——但你们是不是去过挪威，
it was just absolutely treacherous with all the snow. And I think you guys were scheduled to go shoot somewhere or whatever it was, but it was so bad. Then you just went out the back door and did stuff. Exactly, here's what happened. They, they had, you know, our luck was terrible. We had rain storms in Tunisia that caused us, we had to shut down.
到处都是雪，简直险象环生。我想你们当时计划去某个地方拍戏还是怎么的，但天气太糟了。然后你们就从后门走出去拍了。没错，事情是这样的。他们，他们——你知道，我们的运气太差了。我们在突尼斯遇到了沙暴，导致我们不得不停工。
Then we go to Norway, it was like the coldest winter in, I don't know, 11 billion years, whatever it was. And they had found a glacier, which was about an hour and a half from where we were staying, and we were meant to go on snow buggies, because it photographed on camera, it photographed blue. And I remember now, this is the days before a lot of CGI, everything was practical in those days.
然后我们去了挪威，那是——我不知道——110亿年来最冷的冬天，随便什么吧。他们找到了一座冰川，离我们住的地方大约一个半小时车程，我们本打算坐雪地车去，因为在镜头里它拍出来是蓝色的。我记起来了，这是在大量使用CGI之前的日子，那个年代一切都是实景。
So the day arrives for us to go to this blue glacier, and they said, it's impossible. I mean, if we go there, it'll be whited out from the blizzard. So like you say, it was Han Solo rescuing Luke in the snow after getting hit by the Wampa. And if you turn the camera around, there's people on the balcony sipping cocoa watching us. We're about 100 yards from the back of the hotel.
所以，我们要去那座蓝色冰川的日子到了，他们说，这不可能。我是说，如果我们去那儿，暴风雪会把一切都变成一片白色。所以就像你说的，那场景就像汉·索洛在卢克被冰雪怪物袭击后在雪地里救他一样。如果你把镜头转过来，就会看到阳台上有人在喝着热可可看着我们。我们离酒店的背面大概只有100码远。
No way. This is where you cut the belly open on the thing and you got inside? Yes, exactly. No way! That is crazy. They were all enjoying it, but it's funny now because in those days days there wasn't so
不会吧。这就是你剖开那东西的肚子钻进去的地方？对，没错。不会吧！太疯狂了。他们都在享受这一切，但现在想想挺搞笑的，因为在那个年代，没有那么
much security. In other words, when I read Star Wars, I just blew my mind and I said, oh my God, I've got to get my friend Jonathan to read this. So my best friend Jonathan worked down at the LA Art Museum and I passed it to him and he read it and he said, yeah, I don't know how they're going to do this or what it is really. He goes, can I give it to Meredith? I said, yeah, sure. So we passed it all around.
多安保。换句话说，当我读到《星球大战》时，我整个人都被震撼了，我说，哦天哪，我得让我朋友乔纳森读读这个。所以我最好的朋友乔纳森在洛杉矶艺术博物馆工作，我把它递给他，他读完后说，是的，我不知道他们打算怎么拍这东西，或者这到底是什么。他说，我可以把它给梅雷迪思吗？我说，行，当然可以。于是我们在所有人中间传阅。
All my friends read it. It was before everything was coded with your name on it. Where you have to protect it with your life. But it was just a different time. And like I say, I had a blast. I mean, one thing that hit me, I said, you know what I love about this, is you can take from it what you want.
我所有的朋友都读了。那是所有东西都被编上代号、写上你的名字之前的时代。那时你还不需要用生命去保护它。但那确实是一个不同的时代。而且就像我说的，我玩得很开心。我是说，有一件事触动了我，我说，你知道我最喜欢它的什么吗？就是你可以从中学到任何你想要的东西。
In other words, it's effortlessly feminist. The princess is anything but a shrinking violet. She takes over her own rescue, makes Han and Luke look like a couple of chumps. You call this a rescue, give me that gun. And she's standing up to Vader, nose to nose, and really giving him. What I'm saying is is that is just accepted and it's...
换句话说，它是毫不费力的女权主义。公主绝不是一个柔弱的花瓶。她接管了自己的救援行动，把汉和卢克衬托得像两个大笨蛋。你管这叫救援，把那把枪给我。而且她敢于跟维德针锋相对，面贴面地抗衡。我想说的是，这一切都是被理所当然接受的，而且它……
It's ahead of its time. How long was the shoot? Do you remember that? Yeah, it was like, I think it was scheduled for 10 weeks and we went 12. Wow, that's fast. But that was, I mean, that was Star Wars on Empire. It was crazy because it was scheduled for three months, four months.
它超越了那个时代。拍摄持续了多久？你还记得吗？对，大概是，我想计划是10周，我们拍了12周。哇，真快。但这就是——我是说，那是《星球大战》在拍《帝国反击战》时的情况。这太疯狂了，因为它计划拍摄三个月、四个月。
Everybody wrapped and went home and I was still the only human being on the call sheet. There was a puppet, a robot, various snakes and lizards and one human being because they built Dagobah on a sound stage at Elstree. And, you know, I mean, it's amazing that we could get away with that, because when I was reading the script, I said, how are they going to do Yoda? Is it going to be, you know, stop frame animation or whatever?
所有人都杀青回家了，而我仍然是通告单上唯一的活人。现场有一个木偶、一个机器人、各种蛇和蜥蜴，以及一个活人，因为他们在埃尔斯特里制片厂的摄影棚里搭建了达戈巴星。而且，你知道，我是说，我们能蒙混过关真是太惊人了，因为当我读剧本时，我说，他们打算怎么搞出尤达？会是，你知道的，定格动画还是什么的？
I didn't know it was going to be a puppet. But I'm telling you, Frank Oz is such an artist. When he puts that thing on, you're just there. It was so real to me. And he was always breaking down. The eyes would go cock-eyed, the ears wouldn't work. So they had like a stand-in, which was just a foam mold of his face with a piece of blue tape where his eyes are supposed to be.
我不知道那会是个木偶。但我告诉你，弗兰克·奥兹真是一位艺术家。当他把那个东西套上时，你就完全身临其境了。对我来说它是那么真实。而且它总是出故障。眼睛会变成斗鸡眼，耳朵也不听使唤。所以他们有一个替身，那只是他脸的一个泡沫模具，在他眼睛该在的地方贴了一段蓝胶带。
And so every time you see me in a single talking to him, he's not there, but I can, I can be a Jedi. I'm saying to this phone rubber. But again, Frank Oz, I mean, he's, I saw, we're the best of friends. What is it all these years later? He's just one of my favorite people in the business and so talented.
所以每次你看到我和一个单人镜头对话时，他其实不在那儿，但我可以，我可以成为一个绝地武士。我对这个泡沫橡胶块说话。但话说回来，弗兰克·奥兹，我是说，他，我看到，我们是最好的朋友。多少年过去了？他依然是业内我最喜欢的人之一，而且才华横溢。
So amazing. Scottie, before you go, now I'm saying before you go. He's just one of my favorite people in the business and so talented. Oh, it's so amazing Scottie before you go now I'm saying before you go before you go before you go. Do you want to do your Yoda impression for Mark? Oh, yes, let's hear it. Oh Sure, it's never been done. Oh, there you go. There you go. That's great Thank you guys, thank you so much. Thanks Scot good. Thank you, guys. Thank you so much. Thanks, Scotty. I'll see you. Thank you, Scotty. That happens all the time. I was on CNN and Jim Acosta did a Yoda impression on air.
太惊人了。斯科蒂，在你走之前——现在我说的是在你走之前。他依然是业内我最喜欢的人之一，而且才华横溢。哦，太惊人了，斯科蒂，在你走之前——现在我说的是在你走之前，在你走之前，在你走之前。你想为马克模仿一个尤达吗？哦，是的，我们听听。哦，当然，从来没人模仿过。哦，这不就来了。这不就来了。太棒了。谢谢你们，非常感谢。谢谢你，斯科特，很好。谢谢你们，非常感谢。谢谢你，斯科蒂。回头见。谢谢你，斯科蒂。这种事经常发生。我上CNN时，吉姆·阿科斯塔就在直播里模仿了尤达。
Sure did. Yeah. So everybody reverts to their nine-year-old nerd self. Yes, yes. Because it's like unlike anything else, everybody on the planet has seen it and knows what it is. Think about that. Yeah, it's strange.
确实如此。对。所以每个人都退回了他们9岁时的书呆子状态。是的，是的。因为就像其他任何东西都不同，地球上的每个人都看过它并且知道它是什么。想想看。对，这很奇怪。
That's crazy. And I have to tell you, when I read it, I thought, you know, this is, I am so there. I mean, even if I had not gotten the part, I would be dying to see this movie. Right. That's how I felt about it. Do you remember, you know, I love that story
这太疯狂了。我必须告诉你，当我读到它时，我想，你知道，这，我太喜欢了。我是说，即使我没有得到这个角色，我也渴望看到这部电影。对。我当时就是这么觉得的。你还记得，你知道，我喜欢那个故事
that you talk about on Empire where you would never be, if the camera were to turn around and you'd see people sipping cocoa on the deck. Do you look at certain scenes from over the years from over all the movies and go like, well, I've done this before, but you go like, oh, I remember I was really sick that day. Like you watch the take and you go, oh yeah,
你在谈论《帝国反击战》时说过的，如果镜头转过来，你会看到人们在甲板上喝着热可可。多年来，当你回顾所有电影中的某些场景时，你会不会觉得，好吧，我以前做过这个，但你会想，哦，我记得那天我真的很生病。就像你看一条拍摄素材然后说，哦，对了，
that was the day I ate the bad fish. Or that was the first scene we shot or the last scene we shot. Yeah, yeah. I saw them when they came out, but I don't go back and see them again. In fact, when they did the reissue with the special editions, when they called me, I said, oh yeah, if you can send me a copy,
那是我吃了坏鱼的一天。或者那是我们拍的第一场戏或最后一场戏。对，对，对。它们上映时我看了，但我不会回头再去看了。事实上，当他们推出特别版重新上映时，他们打电话给我，我说，哦，行，如果你能寄给我一份，
I'd like to see it. When my kids heard about it, they said, are you kidding? You're not going to go see it in the theater. I said, why do you guys want to see it? You've seen it a bazillion times on video. They said, but never on a big screen. And I was like, oh.
我想看看。我的孩子们听到这个后说，你在开玩笑吧？你不会打算去电影院看吧。我说，为什么你们想看？你们在录像带上看过无数遍了。他们说，但从来没在银幕上看过。然后我就想，哦。
So I did, I saw Empire, the first one, Empire and Jedi, once in the theater. But I haven't seen them again since. And the same with the sequels. You see them and then you just move on. You've seen Star Wars, Empire, and Jedi only once in the movie theaters and never again? No.
所以我去了，我把《帝国》第一部、《帝国》和《绝地归来》在电影院各看了一遍。但从那以后我就再也没看过。续集也是一样。你看过就向前看了。你只在电影院看过《星球大战》、《帝国反击战》和《绝地归来》各一次，之后就再也没看过？没有。
Yeah, I don't watch them on video, to tell you the truth. And there's a certain disconnect because the fans have seen them not only far more recently, but many, many, many, many, many more times than I have. So they'll ask me questions where I go, wait a second, cause this is, do we go to the they go, well, it's not in a movie.
对，说实话我不在录像带上看它们。这之间存在某种脱节，因为粉丝们不仅最近才看过，而且比我看的次数要多得多得多得多得多。所以他们会问我一些问题，让我想，等一下，因为这是，我们去——他们说，哦，它不在电影里。
It's in Splinter of the Mind's Eye. It's a novel by Harry Dean Fox. So they play the games, they read the books, and they know way more about it. I know I've disappointed people. I took a Star Wars quiz once and flunked it. Nathan said, it was multiple choice. What kind of memorial they also test that.
它在《心灵之眼的碎片》里。那是哈里·迪恩·福克斯的一部小说。所以他们玩游戏，读小说，对这些的了解比我多得多。我知道我让人们失望了。我曾经参加过一个《星球大战》知识问答，结果不及格。内森说，那是选择题。还有什么纪念碑，他们也考那个。
Yeah, I was going to ask you when the last time was that you saw the first one, Star Wars. Would have been 97, because it was the 20th anniversary of when it first came out. But I mean, the question's like, what was Hans Solo smuggling? A, jewelry, B, units, C, it was spices. And who knows the, I mean, the minutiae
对，我正想问你上一次看第一部《星球大战》是什么时候。大概是97年吧，因为那是它刚上映20周年。但我是说，那些问题就像是，汉·索洛在走私什么？A，珠宝，B，装置，C，是香料。谁知道这些，我是说，这些粉丝掌握的细节
that these people have is really astonishing. And I hate to disappoint people if I go to these. Didn't they have spice on Dune too? Yeah, they had spice on Dune, yeah. What's with the spices in space? Well, people like the little spicy. I said, it's a real hot commodity in space. Get some tarragon up in space,
真的是惊人的。如果我去参加这些活动却让人失望，我会很难过的。《沙丘》里不也有香料吗？对，他们《沙丘》里也有香料，对。太空里怎么老是有香料？好吧，人们喜欢一点辣的。我说，这是太空里的紧俏商品。在太空中搞点龙蒿，
and you're living up the, you're in the highest of cotton. Yeah, go ahead. What is the craziest fan interaction you've had? Whoa, God. Like, do you have, like, besides today with Scotty? Well, number one, don't sign body parts. Oh, boy. No good can come from that.
那你可就过上好日子，享尽荣华富贵了。对，说吧。你经历过的最疯狂的粉丝互动是什么？哇，天哪。比如，你有过吗，除了今天跟斯科蒂在一起？嗯，第一，不要在身体部位上签名。哦，天哪。那不会有什么好结果的。
Okay. Noted. For the most part, you know what it's like. I mean, when it all happened and went crazy, we were sort of in the center of the storm. So it seemed like everybody was going nuts around us. We weren't going nuts. Right, right, right.
好吧。记下了。大部分时候，你知道那是什么样的。我是说，当这一切发生并走向疯狂时，我们差不多处于风暴中心。所以感觉周围每个人都疯了。我们没有疯。对，对，对。
But it was a different time. I mean, you'd have people just proposition you like, really? Yeah, come on back. Yeah. And we will be right back. And back to the show. Somebody asked me recently, they said,
但那是不同的时代。我是说，会有人直接向你求爱，就像，真的吗？对，回来吧。对。我们马上回来。节目继续。最近有人问我，他们说，
if you had a time machine and you could go back to any time to live, what would it be? And I said, late 70s California. Because it feels like it was like a, just like a kind of unregulated, just kind of a constant sunset. Just good time party. No rules, kind of easy breezy.
如果你有一台时间机器，可以回到任何一个时代去生活，那会是哪个？我说，70年代末的加利福尼亚。因为感觉那就像是一个，一个不受监管的、仿佛永恒日落般的时代。就是好玩聚会。没有规则，轻松惬意。
Yeah, it was great, man. Well, you were nine, but Mark, you, as somebody who was like at the pinnacle of the film industry in that time, it must've been a lot of fun. Yeah, it was, but you always try and say, I haven't changed, everybody else is going bonkers, but you wanna hang on to that,
对，那太棒了，伙计。好吧，你当时9岁，但马克，作为一个当时处于电影行业巅峰的人，那一定非常有趣。对，确实是，但你总是试图说，我没有变，其他人都在发疯，但你想坚持自我，
and plus, I immediately tried to throw myself into things because I wanted to do character parts, I wasn't getting them. You know how these guys, you do one thing well, they want you to do the same thing over and over again. So I went to New York and I was able to do character parts. It wasn't until I discovered animation, I went, oh, where's this been all my life? Because they cast with their ears, not their eyes.
而且，我立刻试图让自己投身于各种事情中，因为我想演性格角色，但我当时接不到。你知道这些家伙的德行，你做成了一件事，他们就想让你一遍又一遍地做同一件事。所以我去了纽约，我能够演性格角色。直到我发现了动画，我才想，哦，这东西我一辈子都在哪儿？因为他们用耳朵选角，而不是用眼睛。
And you're able to play all these parts you'd never get on camera. I went to- Yeah, you're like such play all these parts you'd never get on camera. I would love to. Yeah, you're like such a superstar voiceover actor now. It's incredible. But I'm too short to be the Joker. You know, he's 6'2". Or what, I'm, you know, I'm 5'9", at best.
你能够扮演所有这些你在镜头前永远演不到的角色。我去了——对，你就像是一个——扮演所有这些你在镜头前永远演不到的角色。我很乐意。对，你现在简直是个超级巨星配音演员了。这太不可思议了。但我个子太矮了，当不了小丑。你知道的，他身高6尺2寸。或者别的什么，我，你知道的，我身高顶多5尺9寸。
But wait a minute, this is you as the Joker, which is fucking crazy. It's incredible. Because now, there's a teeny little bit of me in you too. That's why aren't you laughing? Wow. That's incredible. No way.
但等等，这是你扮演的小丑，这他妈太疯狂了。太不可思议了。因为现在，你身上也有我的一点点影子。这就是为什么——你为什么不笑？哇。这太不可思议了。不会吧。
That's from Arkham Asylum. And you know, I had done the role for however long the first iteration came in. There's so many good jokers after me. Kevin Michael Richardson and Jeff Bennett. No, you're one of the most iconic ones now. It's incredible. But what I'm saying is when we got to the video games, because I mean, I get mail in the original incarnation
那是出自《阿卡姆疯人院》。你知道的，从第一版推出开始，我演这个角色演了不知多久。我之后有那么多优秀的小丑配音。凯文·迈克尔·理查森和杰夫·贝内特。不，你现在是最具标志性的小丑之一。这太不可思议了。但我想说的是，当我们开始做电子游戏时——因为我是说，在最初的版本中我收到过邮件
saying, why doesn't the joker kill more people? And you have to say, it's a children's cartoon. Yeah. There's the standards and practices. There was a list of things that you could not do. You could not punch someone directly in the face. You couldn't throw someone through a plate glass window. No nudity, no liquor, no drugs, et cetera.
质问说，为什么小丑不杀更多的人？你不得不回答，这是一部儿童动画片。对。有审查标准。有一张清单列出了你不能做的事情。你不能直接一拳打在别人脸上。你不能把人扔过平板玻璃窗。没有裸露，没有酒精，没有毒品，等等。
Somebody made a drawing, Bruce Timm made a drawing of Batman flying through a glass window with a gin bottle and a hypodermic needle and a girl bare chested, he broke all the rules and won. But by the time we got to the video games, which is, I don't know, I'm bad on time these days, but 10, 15, 20 years later, because Kevin Conroy was always my Batman.
有人画了一幅画，布鲁斯·蒂姆画了一幅画，画的是蝙蝠侠带着一瓶金酒、一支皮下注射器和一个赤裸上胸的女孩飞过玻璃窗，他打破了所有的规则并赢了。但到了我们做电子游戏的时候——我不知道，我最近对时间概念不太好——那是10年、15年、20年之后，因为凯文·康瑞永远是我的蝙蝠侠。
Okay, that's what I was going to ask you, who your Batman was, yeah, Kevin Conroy. When Kevin passed, I said, this is a time for me not to do it anymore because I got to the point where my agent would call and they say, they want you for Joker, I said, this is a time for me not to do it anymore because, you know, I got to the point where my agent would call and they say, they want you for Joker, I'd say, is Kevin doing it? If they said yes, I'd say, then I'm in.
好的，这正是我要问你的，你的蝙蝠侠是谁，对，凯文·康瑞。当凯文去世时，我说，这是我不再扮演这个角色的时候了，因为我到了这种地步：我的经纪人打来电话说，他们想找你演小丑，我会说，这是我不再扮演这个角色的时候了，因为，你知道，我到了这种地步：我的经纪人打来电话说，他们想找你演小丑，我会说，凯文演吗？如果他们说是的，我会说，那算我一个。
I wouldn't even have to read it. But what I couldn't get used to with the video games is that they were for 16 and older, and people did die. I mean, there was, I'm looking at it going, can we say this? Much more sophisticated than the early stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure. But I want to ask you a question, Sean.
我甚至都不用读剧本。但我无法适应电子游戏的一点是，它们是面向16岁及以上人群的，而且人是真的会死的。我是说，有，我看着它心想，我们能说这个吗？比早期那些成熟得多。对，对，对，确实。但我有个问题想问你，肖恩。
Yeah. Because one of the things I miss about living in New York, because we had an apartment there for 19 years, is seeing theater. And I would have loved to have seen you play Oscar Levant. Because I could see it. I could see your face morphing into that character. So long Oscar was such a good, oh dude.
嗯。因为我很怀念住在纽约时的生活——我们在那里有一套公寓19年——其中之一就是看戏剧。我本来很想看你扮演奥斯卡·列凡特。因为我能想象得到。我能看到你的脸融入到那个角色中去。演了那么久奥斯卡真是太棒了，老兄。
And when I was a kid, I mean in the summertime, I could stay up past my bedtime and watch Twilight Zone and Dick Van Dyke and all the shows I loved. And I used to watch Jack Parr and Steve Allen and Oscar Levant fascinated me as a kid because he was effortlessly witty, but he had all these tics and nervous tics and the smoking and all of it.
当我还是个孩子的时候，我是说在夏天，我可以熬夜超过我的睡觉时间，看《阴阳魔界》、《迪克·范·戴克秀》和我所有喜欢的节目。我过去常看杰克·帕尔、史蒂夫·艾伦，奥斯卡·列凡特小时候让我着迷，因为他毫不费力地风趣幽默，但他身上有各种抽搐、神经性抽搐、抽烟等等所有这些。
And I thought, well, you know, I thought you did. I'm going to do it again in London next summer, but just for a limited time, if you find yourself out that way. I'll keep that in mind. Yeah. I'll keep that in mind. Yeah, I'll keep that in mind. Shawn, what a mind blow if you go and you're doing a play that you want a Tony for,
我想，好吧，你知道，我想你演过。我今年夏天晚些时候还会在伦敦再演一次，但时间有限，如果你正好去那边的话。我会记住的。对。我会记住的。对，我会记住的。肖恩，如果你去演一出为你赢得托尼奖的戏，那该有多震撼人心啊，
which again, sorry, just a quick, yeah, you want a Tony for, and then you get to go and you do it on the west end of London, and you've just invited Mark Hamill. I know, that is crazy. To come see you. No, it's true, Mark, this is big for him. This is a big circle.
再次抱歉，只是插一句，对，你为你赢得托尼奖，然后你去伦敦西区演出，而你刚刚邀请了马克·哈米尔。我懂，这太疯狂了。来看你表演。不，真的，马克，这对他的意义重大。这是一个巨大的闭环。
This is huge. It's big for anybody, but it's big. I had a rule with a stage manner. I said, don't tell me who's out front. Because what happened was I came in and everyone said, you know who's in the audience? Jackie Gleason. Yeah, and I thought, oh no, because Harrigan and Hart
这对任何人来说都是大事，但对这事儿……我对舞台经理有个规定。我说，别告诉我谁坐在前排。因为发生过这样的事：我走进后台，每个人都说，你知道观众席里坐着谁吗？杰基·格里森。对，我想，哦不，因为《哈里根与哈特》
had been pitched to Gleason and Carney in the 60s, and it didn't happen for whatever reason. But he's really familiar with that era and that music and all of it. So I mean, it was something I wish I had not known because you want to be totally there, you don't want to be thinking, oh, what did Jackie think of that?
在60年代曾向格里森和卡尼推销过，但不知为什么没拍成。但他对那个时代、那种音乐以及所有这些都非常熟悉。所以，我是说，我真希望自己当时不知道这件事，因为你想完全沉浸在表演中，你可不想脑子里想着，哦，杰基对这个怎么看？
Right, right, for sure, for sure. And sometimes you can't help it because don't want to be thinking, oh, what did Jackie think of that? Right, right, for sure, for sure. And sometimes you can't help it because other cast members would be like, did you hear Meryl Streep's in the audience? Yeah, I mean, it's terrible. So they would tell me, when I would come off, they'd hand me a note and I'd see who was there. But that must have been probably easier for you to do
对，对，当然，当然。有时你又不由自主地会去想，不想去想“哦，杰基对这个怎么看”。对，对，当然，当然。有时你又不由自主，因为其他演员会说，你听说了吗，梅丽尔·斯特里普在观众席里？对，我是说，这太糟糕了。所以他们会告诉我，当我下场时，他们会递给我一张纸条，我就会看到谁在那儿。但对你来说，演
Levant than doing someone as recognizable as Jerry Lewis, and you just killed him. Oh, thanks. You know what, let me put it this way, my review was, it was Oscar Levant, just as I remembered him. Oh God, that's what my dad wrote. Okay, so anyway.
列凡特可能比演杰瑞·刘易斯这种辨识度极高的人物要容易一些，而你把他演得活灵活现。哦，谢谢。你知道吗，这么说吧，对我的评价是：这就是奥斯卡·列凡特，就像我记忆中的那样。哦天哪，我爸就是这么写的。好吧，总之。
So, I can't believe you remember that. Well, did Will and Jason meet on Arrested Development, is that where you guys met? Yes, we did. Yeah, we did. By the way, I'm still mad they canceled that. Everything I like gets canceled. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
所以，我真不敢相信你还记得这个。好吧，威尔和杰森是在《发展受阻》里认识的吗，你们是在那里认识的？是的，我们是的。对，我们是的。顺便说一句，他们取消这部剧我到现在还很生病。我喜欢的一切都被取消了。对，对，对。
And I hold grudges for, I'm still mad they canceled Square Pegs and that was 1982. Oh my God, I remember that. Yeah, Buffalo Bill. Sarah Jessica Parkett never would have done Sex and the City. There you go. Buffalo Bill with Dabney Coleman.
而且我很记仇，对于——我至今还在生《成长的烦恼》（Square Pegs）被取消的气，那是1982年的事。哦天哪，我记得那个。对，还有《布法罗比尔》。莎拉·杰西卡·帕克当年本来绝不会去演《欲望都市》的。你看。有达布尼·科尔曼的《布法罗比尔》。
Oh boy, was that good. Colucci's department. Mark, I got a question for you. When you said you had done the pilot, you got fired from AIDAS enough, is that what happened? Or you got replaced? No, they just, they redid it with, like I say, a different father.
哦天哪，那太棒了。科卢奇的部门。马克，我有个问题要问你。当你说你拍过试播集，你被炒了不知道多少次，是这么回事吗？还是说你被替换了？没有，他们只是，他们重拍了，就像我说的，换了一个不同的父亲。
Right. Well, we call that fired. Yeah. Okay, a different father. Right. Well, we call that fired. Yeah. Okay, yeah, sure, I was fired. But what year, like how soon after that did Star Wars happen? Well, I think, yeah, it was probably six months later or something.
好吧。我们管这叫被炒。对。好吧，一个不同的父亲。对。好吧，我们管这叫被炒。对。好吧，对，没错，我被炒了。但那是哪一年，离《星球大战》过去多久？嗯，我想，大概是六个月后吧什么的。
So what's crazy about it is, the reason I bring it up, and I've talked about this before, is six months before I got the pilot for Arrested Development, that changed my life, I got let go from a is, six months before I got the pilot for Arrested Development that changed my life, I got let go from a show, they replaced my character, actually they just wrote him out, and at the time I was like, oh, it was a series regular on a sitcom,
所以这最疯狂的地方在于——我提起这个是因为我以前也说过——在我拿到改变我人生的《发展受阻》试播集的六个月前，我被一部剧开除了。是这样，在我拿到改变我人生的《发展受阻》试播集的六个月前，我被一部剧开除了，他们换掉了我的角色，其实就是把我的角色写死了，当时我觉得，哦，我是情景喜剧里的常驻演员，
I was gonna make money and all this kind of shit, and I got so bad, and six months later, I didn't know that the universe had made space for me to have to do the thing that would change my life. Oh, see? And so it's very, so now I didn't become a global superstar the way you did, but still it like was the thing that really propelled me and gave me a career.
我本可以赚钱和搞这些乱七八糟的，我当时糟透了。而六个月后，我并不知道宇宙已经为我腾出了空间，让我去做好那件将改变我人生轨迹的事。哦，你看？所以这是非常——所以虽然我没有像你那样成为全球超级巨星，但它依然是真正推动我并给我带来职业生涯的事物。
I had a similar thing happen. I got a part on the Texas Wheelers with Jack Elam, you know that cockeyed character actor from Westerns. Now, when he did Support Your Local Sheriff, Support Your Local Gunfire, then he got to show his comedy chops. And this pilot was an irreverent, it was like the anti-Waltons.
我也经历过类似的事情。我在《德州威廉姆者》里得到了一个角色，搭档是杰克·伊兰，你知道西部片里那个斜眼性格演员。当时，当他演《支持你当地的治安官》、《支持你当地的枪手》时，他展现出了自己的喜剧天赋。而这个试播集非常叛逆，有点像反《沃尔顿家族》。
Gary Busey was the titular head of the family because Jack comes back in the pilot having been in jail for stealing a car or whatever. But my character, Doobie, Doobie Wheeler, was, what I loved about it was he was hilarious, but he was so serious about himself. He took himself very seriously, thought he was a womanizer even though he was a virgin, all these things. It was really for its time, in 1974, I remember New York Times said, possibly the finest bucolic comedy since Tobacco Road.
加里·布西是这个家庭的名义上的大家长，因为杰克在试播集里因为偷车之类的罪名坐牢回来。但我的角色，杜比，杜比·威廉姆者，我喜欢他的一点是，他非常滑稽，但他对自己却极其严肃。他把自己看得很重，尽管自己还是个处男，却觉得自己是个花花公子，诸如此类。在1974年那个时代，这真的很超前，《纽约时报》曾说，这可能是自《烟草路》以来最精彩的田园喜剧。
And I said, oh man, not only is this a breakout part, but it's a comedy part, because in most parts, I was playing real straightforward high school students and that kind of stuff. So I was really jazzed and it came out and it made 13 episodes, it got canceled after four episodes and I was devastated because I said, I'm not going to get another good part like this.
我说，天哪，这不仅是一个能让人一炮走红的角色，而且是个喜剧角色，因为在大多数角色中，我演的都是那种循规蹈矩的高中生之类的人物。所以我当时真的兴奋极了，它播出了，拍了13集，播了4集就被砍了，我当时简直心碎欲绝，因为我说，我再也接不到这么好的角色了。
I just don't see it happening. I was really, really depressed. But the upshot is, if that had run, then I wouldn't have been able to do Star Wars. Exactly, that was my point. And we would have had Freddy Krueger out there swinging around a lightsaber. I mean, and that would have been... Imagine all the scratch marks on Vader's cape.
我就是觉得不会有了。我当时真的、真的很沮丧。但结果是，如果那部剧继续播下去，我就没法去演《星球大战》了。没错，这就是我的意思。那样的话，我们就会看到弗莱迪·库克在外面挥舞着光剑了。我是说，那将会……想象一下维德披风上会有多少抓痕。
Actually, it would have been Will Seltzer and Terry Nunn from... She was in a band... Oh, I can't remember now. Terry Nunn. Terry Nunn, she was in... not Joy Division, I don't know. You Google it, but I mean, it was, like I say, it was cast as a set, there was no mixing and matching. Right, right, you came as a package. Berlin, she's the singer from Berlin.
其实，那会是威尔·塞尔瑟和特里·纳恩——她曾在一个乐队里……哦，我现在想不起来了。特里·纳恩。特里·纳恩，她曾在……不是乔·迪vision乐队，我不知道。你们去谷歌一下吧，但我是说，它就像我说的，作为一个整体选角的，没有什么混搭。对，对，你们是作为一个整体来的。柏林乐队，她是柏林乐队的主唱。
That's it. The band Berlin. Thank you. You know, Mark, I have, as I always say with my guests that I bring on, that I have 7,000 questions. But I wanted to, you know, we gotta let you go because it's been an hour and we promised we'd only have you for an hour here. So the, you know, all the stuff I wanted to ask you
就是这样。柏林乐队。谢谢。你知道，马克，正如我对待请来的嘉宾时常说的那样，我有一万个问题想问。但我想，你知道的，我们得让你走了，因为已经一个小时了，我们答应过只占用你一个小时。所以，你知道，我所有想问你的关于
about just like, you know, coming back to the Force Awakens and what was that with J.J. Abrams, but anyway, we'll talk about that at dinner sometime, hopefully. But I watched the fall of The House of Usher. I thought you were incredible. You have The Life of Chuck coming out on Netflix, which looks so good. You have The Long Walk, that Stephen King movie
比如回到《原力觉醒》，跟J·J·艾布拉姆斯的合作是怎么回事，不管怎样，我们以后有空吃晚餐时再聊吧。不过我看了《厄舍古屋的倒塌》。我觉得你太不可思议了。你在网飞有即将上映的《查克的一生》，看起来太棒了。你还有《长途步行》，那是斯蒂芬·金的电影，
that comes out in 2025, which is fucking, that looks incredible. And you've been getting all these accolades for The Wild Robot. The whole, like, everything. I'm in the new SpongeBob SquarePants movie. You're in the new SpongeBob SquarePants movie. You're in the new SpongeBob SquarePants movie. Have you seen Wild Robot?
将于2025年上映，那他妈的，看起来太不可思议了。你还因为《荒野机器人》获得了各种赞誉。整个，就像，一切。我参演了新的《海绵宝宝》电影。你在新的《海绵宝宝》电影里。你在新的《海绵宝宝》电影里。你看过《荒野机器人》吗？
I mean, it's funny that we should bring it up now that we're wrapping up. I have, I've seen it. It's so great. I heard it's fantastic. It's so great. Look, I read the book, this book by Peter Brown, there's a reason it was the number one bestseller
我是说，现在节目快结束了我们才提起这个，挺搞笑的。我看过，我看过了。太棒了。我听说这片子极好。太棒了。听着，我读过这本书，彼得·布朗写的这本书，它能成为《纽约时报》畅销书榜首并赢得所有这些奖项是有原因的。它是如此完美，以至于我想，请千万别把它搞砸了。如果他们能捕捉到这本书20%的魅力，我们就赢了。而且他们保留了插图，跟书里一模一样。演员阵容简直好得超乎想象。我一直在给孩子们读这本书。对，这太棒了。
in the New York Times and won all these awards. It is so perfect that I thought, please don't mess this up. If they can capture even 20% of the charm of this book, we're on a winner. And they kept the illustrations, the exact same as in the book. The cast is beyond great. I was reading the book to the kids. Yeah, it's amazing.
但它是如此轻松自然，在这个时代又是如此意义深远，关于包容和为了更大利益团结在一起。这就是他们让我出戏的地方。老实说，如果说实话，那就是他们……鉴于我们正在经历的一切，这显得非常应景。这是一部巨大的热门作品，而且得到了认可，这很棒。体量太庞大了。
But it's so effortless and it's so meaningful in this time about tolerance and joining together for the greater good. That's where they lost me. To be honest, if I'm being real, that's where they... It seemed very timely, given what we're going through. It's a huge hit and it's like getting recognized, which is great. It's massive.
这真的、真的很棒。我太幸运了。好吧，马克，我只想说，就我个人而言，你是一个如此令人愉快的人，我很高兴你这么讨人喜欢，因为对我来说，就像许多我这个年纪的人一样，你是我们是谁、我们想成为什么样的人的一部分，而且事实上
It's really, really good. I'm so lucky. Well, Mark, I just say just for me, you're such a delight and I'm so excited that you're such a delight because myself, like so many people my age, you're such a part of just who we are and who we wanted to be and the fact
你保持了这样一种善良、温暖和正派的品格，这似乎——简直是一个巨大的宽慰，谢谢你来到这里，伙计。谢谢你这么说，但我必须告诉你，这些人，当他们走到你面前时，你知道，谈论起这些，他们总是用非常私人的方式，你知道，
that you have maintained such a kindness and a warmth and a decency in your person, it seems, is just, is such a relief, and thank you for being here, buddy. Thank you for saying that, but I have to tell you, these people, when they come up to you, you know, and talk about it, they put it in such personal terms, you know,
比如它帮助我度过了我母亲、我父亲的离婚，或者诸如此类的事情。我永远都不会听腻。这就像是，哦不，我们别再谈那个了。我想听听他们要说些什么，你知道的？我想到了这个时候，由于我对细节的记忆有点模糊，你知道的，因为我没看它那么多次。
that it helped me get through my mother's, my father's divorce, or you know, whatever it is. I never get tired of it. It's like, oh no, let's not talk about that again. I want to hear what they have to say, you know? I think at this point, since I'm sort of soft focus on the details, you know, because I haven't seen it that much.
说实话，卢克在续集里的存在感很轻。他在第一部里演了一个无声的客串，在最后一部里也只是个客串，所以我只有中间那部分。但我想说的是，这是一件我不会视为理所当然的事情，而且我觉得自己太幸运了，因为人们会说，哦，难道你不会为自己除了卢克之外什么都不被记住而感到遗憾吗？而事实上，我从没指望过因任何事情而被记住。我只是想要一件宏大的事情。
And really, Luke had a light presence in the sequels. He did a silent cameo in the first one and a cameo in the last one, so I only had that middle part. But what I'm saying is, it's something that I don't take for granted, and I think how lucky I am, because people say, oh, aren't you sorry that you're remembered for nothing, but Luke, when in fact, I never expected to be remembered for anything. I just wanted a giant thing.
如果有人真的这么说，那该是多么荒谬的一件事。这绝对是一件他妈的荒谬至极的说法。这是娱乐史上最有名的电影。就像你说的，那种连接感，我要重复杰森说过的话，对于一个在多伦多长大、第一次在市里蒙普兰萨特的普莱森特剧院看这部电影的孩子来说。
What an absurd thing if anybody actually says that. What an absolutely absurd fucking thing to say. It's the most famous film in the history of entertainment. And like you said, it's that connection, and I'm going to echo what Jason said for a kid who grew up in Toronto and saw it the first time at the, what was it, the Pleasant Theater on Mount Pleasant in Toronto, in the city.
多年后的今天我能坐在这里跟你说话，你所做的事情产生的影响。但更重要的是你还是个好人。对，最棒的是你还是个大好星，这真的很了不起。我很感激肖恩提到《厄舍古屋的倒塌》，因为我习惯于在动画里扮演非常诡异和非典型的角色——这真的很了不起，也很重要。我很感激肖恩提到《厄舍古屋的倒塌》，
For me to be here all these years later talking to you, the impact that what you did. But that you're a good person too. Yeah, and then on top of it, you're a great dude is really something. And I appreciate Sean mentioning Follow the House of Usher, because I'm used to doing really bizarre is really something that is important. And I appreciate Sean mentioning Follow the House of Usher
因为我习惯于在动画里扮演非常诡异和非典型的角色。这是迈克·弗拉纳根第一次让我去演一个在动画里会觉得很常规的真人角色。对，你演得太棒了。因为我想，这就是那个没有灵魂、邪恶的反社会分子。
because I'm used to doing really bizarre and atypical roles in animation. This is the first time Mike Flanagan asked me to do a character that would have been routine in animation on camera. Yeah, you were so great. Because I thought, here's this guy who is the soulless, evil sociopath.
他们自然而然地想到了我。对，没错。我是这么说的。我非常感谢迈克·弗拉纳根。我们看了这部剧，我太喜欢了。你把这个角色演得出神入化。我太喜欢你演的那个角色了。非常出人意料，看的时候绝对让人惊心动魄。而且真的是那种
Naturally, they thought of me. Yeah, sure. That's what I said. I'm so grateful to Mike Flanagan. But we watched it, I just love that. You knocked it out of the park. I loved you in that part. It was so unexpected and absolutely thrilling to watch. And it was really one of those things where
当我读到剧本时我在想，我该怎么演？我通常对角色的要求有一个轻微的概念，以使整部剧顺利运作。这是一个庞大的群戏。迈克的作品都很棒，你知道的，《鬼入侵》、《午夜弥撒》。所以我是他的超级粉丝，我想，
when I read it I thought, how am I going to do this? I usually have a slight concept of what is required of your character to make the whole thing work. And it was a huge ensemble. Mike does these wonderful, you know, Haunting of Hill House, Haunting of Blind Man, or Midnight Mass. So I was a huge fan of his and I thought,
即使我不知道该怎么演，如果他觉得我能行，那凭老天爷我也要把它演好。但这真的很吓人，因为当我坐飞机去温哥华时，我心里依然没底。渐渐地，他的服装——我帮他挑选了服装，正如我对发型师说的，这家伙早上起床时，
even though I don't know how to do this, if he thinks I can do it, then by gosh, I'm going to do it. But it was really scary, because when I was flying up Vancouver, I still had no idea. And little by little, his wardrobe helped me pick out his wardrobe, as I said to the hair people, this guy wants to get out of bed in the morning,
只想用毛巾随手一抹，所以头发剪短点让它顺着贴在头上就行。别翘起来，就贴着。然后他们找到了眼镜，找到了帽子，最后来的是——这真的很有趣，因为我们之前没讨论过，但我们在罗德里克和玛德琳·厄舍的办公室拍一场戏时，我说，我该怎么传达这家伙
just draw with one swipe of the towel, so cut it short enough so it just lays down. Doesn't stick up, just lays down. Then they found the glasses, they found the hat, and the last thing that came, which was really interesting, because we didn't discuss it, but we were doing a scene in the Roderick and Madeleine Usher's office, and I said, how do I convey that this guy
内心已经彻底死了呢？我开始这样说话：所以，我给他打电话，他没回我们。我找了个人盯着他。我之前没讨论过这个，也没有说我要进去用这种声音演。我只是在那个当下结束时问，我应该这么做吗？我照做了，拍了几个机位之后，
is completely dead inside? And I just started talking like this, so I called him, he didn't call us back. I got a guy looking out for him. I didn't discuss it at the end of the time and I didn't say I'm going to go in and do this voice. I just end the moment, said should I do it? And I did and after we did a couple of setups,
那天晚些时候，迈克从我身边走过，只说了一句：喜欢这个声音。我说，哦，我找到感觉了。太棒了，你变成了一个完全不同的人。我喜欢这样。是的，这太罕见了。你知道当有人跳出你以往为人熟知的固有框架去思考时有多令人兴奋吗，
later in the day Mike walked past me and just said, love the voice. And I said, oh, I'm home. So great, you became a completely different person. I love that. Yes, and that's so rare. You know how exciting it is that someone thinks outside the box of what you're known for,
我真的很幸运。然后，他又让我在《查克的一生》里演了一个小角色，再次地，他说，我根据斯蒂芬·金的小说给你发个剧本，里面有个角色适合你，巴拉巴拉。所以我期待着，好吧，你有斯蒂芬·金，你有迈克·弗拉纳根，这将会是有史以来最震撼的恐怖史诗。我告诉你们，它是关于一个叫查克的男孩最甜蜜、最辛酸、最温暖的故事，
and I'm really lucky. And then again, he cast me in a small part in The Life of Chuck, which again, he said, I'm going to send you the script based on a Stephen King novella and there's a part for you in it and blah, blah, blah. So I'm expecting, okay, you've got Stephen King, you've got Mike Flanagan, this is going to be the horror epic of all time. I'm telling you guys, it is the sweetest, poignant, warm story of a boy named Chuck
贯穿了他生命的四个不同阶段。他长大后成了汤姆·希德勒斯顿。但这打破了他们两人的常规。我们在制作时我对制片人特雷弗·梅西说，我不知道我们该怎么宣传这部电影，因为它是无法用言语形容的。我是说，你必须亲自看才能领会。
at four different stages of his life. He grows up to be Tom Hiddleston. But it's so atypical of both of them. And I said to them when we made it, I said to Trevor Macy, the producer, I said, I don't know how we're going to promote this because it's indescribable. I mean, you have to see it to get it.
这太棒了。而且你知道，我——必须看才能领会。对，我迫不及待想看了。这太棒了。而且你知道，我在他家里的一间小房间里看过一次。但当我在多伦多国际电影节跟观众一起看时，那简直是一个启示。它虽然没参展竞赛单元，但被评为了最受欢迎的电影，因为观众如此深地融入其中，以至于那些你没料到会有反应的地方都得到了反应——他们笑了，他们鼓掌，人们热泪盈眶。我是说，这真的很特别。那部叫什么来着？那叫《查克的一生》，它是倒叙的，第三幕、第二幕、第一幕，我只在片尾的第一幕里出现，但汤姆演得太棒了。演他12岁时候的这个男孩，本杰明·佩亚杰克，记住这个名字，因为这
And it's amazing. And you know, I it to get it. Yeah, I can't wait to see it. It's amazing. And you know, I saw it at his house once, just in a little room. But when I saw it at the Toronto Film Festival with an audience, it was a revelation. It wasn't in competition, but it was voted favorite film because the audience becomes such a part of it that things that you didn't expect to get reactions got reactions they laugh they applauded people were in tears I mean it's really special I'm what's that one called it's called the life of Chuck and it's told backwards is act three act two act one and I'm only in Act 1 at the end of the picture, but Tom is great. This boy that plays him at age 12, Benjamin Payjack, remember that name, because this
个孩子，他会唱歌，会跳舞，他曾在百老汇复排的《欢乐音乐人》（由休·杰克曼主演）中扮演罗恩·霍华德演过的那个角色。我告诉你们，我是说，我真希望他是我的亲孙子，他简直太惊艳了。好吧，我喜欢这样。好吧，我迫不及待想看了。对，那个和——那部在五月上映。
kid, he can sing, he dances, he played the, he was the Ron Howard part in the revival of Music Man on Broadway, Hugh Jackman. And I'm telling you, I mean, I just, I wish you were my real grandson, he's just phenomenal. Well, I love that. Well, I can't wait to see it. Yeah, that and- And that comes out in May.
太棒了。在五月。然后还有《长途步行》，我迫不及待了，因为那是个疯狂的概念。《长途步行》，顺便说一句，我读了那本书，我想，呃，这——因为我总是在看到剧本之前先读原著。这太折磨人了，太可怕了。
Fantastic. In May. And then, and the long walk, I can't wait because that's a crazy concept. The long walk, and by the way, I read that, I'm thinking, ugh, this, because I always read the books before they even seen the script. It's excruciating, it's so horrible.
我是说，我想。一百个十几岁的男孩被迫参加一项年度活动，他们必须以恒定的速度行走，否则就会被杀掉，对吧？诸如此类的事情。对，有人随时准备朝他们脑袋开枪。我是说，我告诉你，这太恶心了，我想。这不可能。
I mean, I thought. A hundred teenage boys are forced to participate like in an annual thing where they have to walk at a constant pace or they get killed, right? Or something like that. Yeah, there's people ready to shoot them in the head. I mean, I'm telling you, it's so gross, I thought. There's no way.
我是说，我可能会看看，但我可演不了这种东西。再说一次，我儿子读了之后说，你疯了吗？这太棒了。你必须演。但光是暴力，枪支暴力本身——好在现在他们用电脑特效制作，你不需要用血包，每个人都——
I mean, I'll watch it maybe, but I can't do something like this. And again, my son read it and said, are you nuts? This is fantastic. You got to do it. But just the violence, the gun violence alone, now luckily, it's now they do it CGI where you don't have to do squibs and everybody goes.
每次拍摄后现场都会清理干净，因为那个东西会飞溅出来。但我是说，这真的很恶心。我喜欢这样。我太喜欢了。好吧，你接下来有很多好作品要上映，顺便说一句，如果你有什么《星球大战》的纪念品想处理掉，请送给我。
It gets cleaned up after each take because the bug goes flying. But I mean, it is really gross. I love that. I love it. Well, you got a lot of good stuff coming up, and by the way, if you have any Star Wars memorabilia you want to get rid of, please send it over.
好的。你具体什么时候去伦敦演奥斯卡？七月到九月在巴比肯艺术中心。大概三个月？就像，对，不，七周。好吧，七周。七月底开始。七周。好吧，七周。七周。七月底开始。
Yeah. And when specifically are you going to do Oscar in London? July through September at the Barbeque Theater. Like three months? Like, yeah, well, no, seven weeks. Okay, seven weeks. The end of July, too. seven weeks. Okay, seven weeks. Seven weeks. The end of July, too.
是的。你具体什么时候在伦敦演《奥斯卡》？七月到九月在巴比肯艺术中心。大概三个月？差不多，不，七周。好的，七周。七月底开始。七周。好的，七周。七周。七月底开始。
Okay. Sounds like fun. Summer in England. Yeah, yeah. Here we go. Mark, it's been an honor and a privilege to talk to you. I echo what these guys say. I just can't even believe I'm talking to you.
好的。听起来很有趣。英国的夏天。对，对。我们走吧。马克，能和您谈话是我的荣幸。我附和这些家伙的话。我简直不敢相信我在跟你说话。
This is crazy. When I listened to you guys do with Steve Martin and Martin Short, I said, well, after this, I've gotta be a letdown. Nobody can top those two. It was one of the best episodes you've done. You hit the peak, sir. Such a joy.
这太疯狂了。当我听你们采访史蒂夫·马丁和马丁·肖特时，我想，在这之后，我肯定会让人失望。没有人能超越那两个人。这是你们做过的最好的单集之一。你达到了巅峰，先生。太高兴了。
Thank you for joining us, Mark. Thank you, Mark. Thanks for having me. What a thrill. If you ever get hungry, call me, I'll have a meal. Thanks, Mark. What a kind man you are. Bye, buddy.
谢谢你加入我们，马克。谢谢你，马克。谢谢邀请。真是太刺激了。如果你饿了，给我打电话，我请你吃饭。谢谢，马克。你真是个好人。再见，老兄。
Bye. Bye. Well, Sean, you a kind man you are. Bye, buddy, bye. Bye, hon. Hey. Well, Sean, you gonna be all right? You need to mop, you need to towel off or? Yes, I do, I was sweating a little bit the whole time. I mean, my Lord, wasn't that crazy? He was supposed to come on for a long time.
再见。再见。好吧，肖恩，你真是个好人。再见，老兄，再见。再见，亲爱的。嘿。好吧，肖恩，你没事吧？你需要擦擦，需要一条毛巾还是？是的，我需要，我刚才一直在流汗。我的天哪，难道不疯狂吗？他本该待很长时间的。
And now what? You just couldn't, now what? I know, I'm done. You said Mark Hamlin, now what? I mean, I guess you can make your way through the cast, of course Harrison would be amazing. Yeah, Carrie would be hard to book, I'm sure. She would like that joke.
现在呢？你简直不能，现在呢？我知道，我完了。你说了马克·哈米尔，现在呢？我的确，我想你可以把演员阵容过一遍，当然哈里森会很棒。是的，凯莉很难预约，我确定。她会喜欢那个笑话的。
You want us to cut, you want to say cut that now, or no, she would love it. She would love that joke. But I wouldn't, you know, I didn't even get to ask him about, you know, the fact that actors, we kind of measure our lives in like milestone of jobs, right, we all talk, I was talking about like, I was doing this at that time and this,
你想让我们剪掉，你想说现在就剪掉，还是不，她会喜欢的。她会喜欢那个笑话的。但我不会，你知道，我甚至没能问他关于，你知道，演员们以工作里程碑来衡量我们的生活，对吧，我们都在谈论，我当时在做这个，那个，
and for him, Star Wars never, there's no end to that milestone. Like he reprised Luke on Mandalorian with Jon Favreau, you know, and like he is so open and willing to share, to not shy away from it and to embrace it, which I think is really important. Yeah, and he loves the legacy of it. He's not frustrated that that was then and this is now.
对她来说，《星球大战》永无止境，那个里程碑没有尽头。就像他在乔恩·费儒的《曼达洛人》中再次饰演卢克一样，你知道的，他是那么的开放和乐于分享，不回避它，而是去拥抱它，我认为这真的很重要。是的，他热爱它的传奇色彩。他并没有因为那是过去而现在是现在而感到沮丧。
I like that about him. Sometimes they play it down like, yeah, yeah, I didn't. You're like, no, no, no, it's a big thing. Yeah, like own it. Yeah, he was the star of, is the star of the biggest film, most famous film in the history of our business. Totally.
我喜欢他这一点。有时他们把它轻描淡写地说，是的，是的，我没有。你会觉得，不，不，不，这是一件大事。是的，就像勇敢承认一样。是的，他是我们行业历史上最大、最著名的电影的明星。完全同意。
So it's just a remarkable thing, and thank God he's proud of it. I know, incredible. Which is your favorite film of all the films, Seanny? Well, The Empire Strikes Back is pretty special. Yeah? I mean, I lived for all of them, but like... What was the thing about Empire Strikes Back?
所以这真是一件了不起的事情，谢天谢地他为此感到骄傲。我知道，太不可思议了。肖尼，在所有的电影中你最喜欢哪一部？嗯，《帝国反击战》非常特别。是吗？我的意思是，我为所有这些电影而活，但像……《帝国反击战》吸引人的地方是什么？
It was just, I don't know, it was a little more sophisticated. It was a little more... We'll turn it back into a buy here. I'm not. There's a little more. Oh no, I was going to do a special one. No, because I know a lot of people felt like that was... Well, A New Hope is the first one, so it's like the first time you see it, so it special one. No, because I know a lot of people felt like that was, well,
这只是，我不知道，它更成熟一些。它更……我们在这儿把它转回SmartLess。我没有。还有一点。哦不，我要做一个特别的。不，因为我知道很多人觉得那是……嗯，《新希望》是第一部，所以就像你第一次看到它一样，所以它很特别。不，因为我知道很多人觉得那是，嗯，
A New Hope is the first one, so it's like the first time you see it, so it's amazing. Yeah, it's huge. Empire Strikes Back is an amazing cinematic feat. And people weren't, they didn't love as much. And this is a very special return of the Jedi. Jedi, Jedi. Jedi, Jedi, we will allow.
《新希望》是第一部，所以就像你第一次看到它一样，所以它太棒了。是的，太宏大了。《帝国反击战》是一部了不起的电影成就。人们并没有，他们没有那么爱它。这是一个非常特别的《绝地归来》。绝地，绝地。绝地，绝地，我们可以允许。
I know, but it stammers! It's allowed for you! Alright, fine. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
我知道，但它结巴了！这是允许你的！好吧，好吧。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。《SmartLess》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔比科100%有机纯手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。